各位观众朋友 您好 欢迎收看新闻节目。
零点的中商在神州大地长民。
各族人女协守迎来新千年的QQ。
是即时通信的一个产品。
而即时通信是在互联网的这个环境下。
人们用于沟通联络一个非常方便的一个新的通信方式。
一股三路铃与弹旋针的纠结。
由来已解
被业界刑产成为新国电脑公司首席执行官。
潮博斯9号在年度会长上宣布。
公司名创由苹果电脑公司改为苹果公司。
同时还展示了苹果手无法来。
这支电脑网络是电脑电脑。
但摄像网络是人面人。
很充斥人物
这个新闻的新闻
阿里巴巴社区的舞台。
来自阿里巴巴
经营发生公司实际控制人物。
这几个案情是有准备出来吗？
本来以为是做火箭。
结果做的是穿天猴。
穿了一下就没了
二体脚到上都爆了。
商业化这个层面
跟社区建设的两个部分。
真的是水深火热
完全不一样
这次就不是二体脚了。
但是商业化角度来说。
你别说外界了
内部大家都有点迷糊。
也不知道在怎么办。
你确实着急
总得挣钱
用一句最直白
最不绕弯子的方式介绍一下。
他说小红书乱七八糟。
但是生机薄薄
陈锐就问徐一
你是想要卖一辈子。
糖水
到底是谁问谁
陈锐当时是这么问的。
他说你是想就做一个爱好者的社团。
还是想正儿八经做一家互联网公司。
你不懂社区会死
你只懂社区
也会死
眼光不能太聚焦
必占
未来有可能会倒闭。
但绝不会变质
你看看
谢谢主席
谢谢对方
这仪式敢拉满
谢谢小蕾
你就说
没有铁片
那转转是什么？
神奇小路是什么？
妙界是什么？
那不就是往里硬栽吗？
硬栽了
这不跟铁片一模一样吗？
你栽的其实是麻烦。
简直是狼狈
它做了一个非常天才的设计。
这是可能小宇宙历史上最重要的设计。
时间戳评论
它跟弹幕对于视频的意义是一样的。
一曲同工了
各位
这就是社区
社区不是一群人在看一个东西而已。
社区是你能看到成千上万的人跨越时间。
跨越空间
跟你在这时刻
这个地方
一起相聚
教会了
公明了
社区Bream People Together。
半大铁第214期大宝开始。
大家好
我是刘飞
我是肖磊
不容易
怎么不容易
我们今天又有金主朋友了。
欢迎
今天这期节目有
网易悠悠远程
赞助不出
新朋友
咱们这两期聊的是社区产品。
我还真就是从社区产品里。
从X和小红书看到的。
很多人推荐悠悠远程。
很多AI相关的开发者和创作者都在安利。
我也试着去用了用。
用了一阵子
感觉还是挺满意的。
刘飞一向是特别喜欢尝试。
这就是口碑传播的力量。
因为大家都提到了。
就想去悠悠看
悠悠远程到底是做什么的。
用一句最直白
最不绕弯子的方式介绍一下。
那就是
能够远程所见及所得的。
控制一个电脑设备。
就相当于你用你的另一台电脑。
或者手机
就能直接控制
一台Windows或者Mac了。
那这种远程工具
可想而知
既然要远程控制
它最重要的特性就是两个字。
第一个快
第二个稳
而悠悠远程用起来。
速度是真的快
连上去几乎没什么卡顿。
只要你家网速有保障。
这个中间不太存在其他的问题。
巧夫难为无敏之吹。
咱家没连网
这事也办不了
你不能用它来连网。
稳定性也特别好
长时间挂着也不会掉线。
而且还提供了很多功能。
非常方便
我们来说两个场景。
用悠悠远程到底能干什么呢？
什么时候用
第一个场景就是AI Coding。
不踩
业余时间也略做点小开发。
自己就做着玩嘛？
本身也是互联网大厂出来的。
但做AI Coding的朋友。
大家都会发现
有一个现状就是你现在Coding。
AI写的时候你得等。
所以它其实是一个。
操作一分钟
等待两小时的工作。
经常这样
你要是纯坐在电脑前面等。
这点等
很折磨
不是起来做俩符合成。
有了悠悠远程它就不一样了。
你可以用手机随时随地。
控制这个电脑
你输指令改参数的时候。
可以直接用手机完成。
就跟老板一样
我打开摺地平手机。
卡卡卡
输几个字
那边给我搞定一个东西了。
大家共情了
而且
共情家里的电脑了。
悠悠远程
还有一个中端功能。
可以直接
接入命令行界面
你就不用掉出
整个图形界面了
你就可以连上
被控端的命令行
搭配
CLI用Cloud Code。
或者Codex
这种AI工具
就非常方便
你直接敲命令
直接看这些结果
就跟在本地一样
而且由于只传输文本。
对网速的要求非常低。
所以这就相当于
你网速不好的地方。
你也能用它来指挥。
做很多事情
这点很重要
在高铁商
在机场
网络不那么好的时候。
还能用省流量的方法。
可能在国外有的地方。
也没那么方便
流量费也贵
现在
大家确实也会说
你看Codex和Cloud Code。
它不也有远程连接功能吗？
但是很多地方
依然还是不方便
遇到一些问题的时候。
比如说
你后台可能需要扫个码。
你登录一个什么账号。
你可能需要看到界面。
包括划块验证
包括有一些GOI的工具操作。
包括你最后让它
设计一个什么样的元素。
什么样的视觉效果。
你还是想看一下
这些都得
能直接看到
电脑的界面才行
更适合中国人的
就是悠悠远程
第二个场景
是办公
刚才说的AI Codex。
大家会觉得
跟我关系不是特别大。
但是办公这个
对于大部分朋友
除了财务自由
在海岛上吹风的朋友们。
基本上都是需要的。
很多人可能会遇到一个情况。
下班了
领导突然要一份文件。
但是那个文件
你在公司电脑里面。
怎么办
很多朋友就得
只能把电脑背回家。
这很麻烦
看到公司电脑
就已经全是包味
很难受
但悠悠远程这个时候。
就能用得上了
你周末在家里
在旅游的时候
突然要发份文件
直接悠悠远程连上去。
把这个文件导出来。
也就可以了
能解决很多现实问题。
悠悠远程为什么？
我们说它除了快和稳。
还有很多很方便的功能。
那就涉及到
它做了很多特性
比如说你可能就会问。
哎呦
悠悠远程连接
岂不是要一直开着电脑呢？
不用
悠悠远程支持
远程开机
这个功能很重要
你出门的时候
你很难预判
是不是临时需要远程。
控制电脑
每次出门都开着电脑。
它又浪费电
又消耗电脑的电池。
而且有些时候公司里。
你自己不关
保安也会给你关了。
对
接着用电
你还得贴个大条
不能关电脑
而且很多公司
确实是不允许
长时间不关机的
而悠悠远程
支持远程开机
这个估计很多朋友不知道。
现在一般的电脑
的网卡里面
都是自带远程开机功能的。
你可能都没用上过。
它有叫醒服务
所以你通过网关
或者路由器
可以随时随地
把家里那台电脑叫醒。
0000 morning call。
现在这个它非常方便。
还有一个就是文件传输。
而且它是支持跨端传输的。
就不管是Mac, Windows, Android, iOS。
它都支持各端之间传输。
我们现在都知道
你要跨端
它挺麻烦的
你还得通过网盘
或者什么东西中转一下。
而直接用悠悠远程。
它就可以直接传输。
传输速度也挺不错的。
比网盘要快很多
有一些小细节做的也很好。
比如说
你可以直接看到
Windows电脑里面的文件管理器。
直接拖拽文件
就可以弄了
比微信传文件还方便。
有点虚拟机操作感是吗？
对
在你电脑上有一个虚拟。
出来的一个虚拟机。
然后这个过程当中。
我用的就特别多
我甚至有的时候
就是专为了传文件。
我哪怕都在电脑面前。
我也要打开又远程。
用它来帮我传文件。
图片、视频文件
甚至包括整个文件夹都可以的。
除了这些场景
你既然是远程能连接了。
你就可以发掘很多新的场景。
比如说玩游戏
它支持手机直接玩PC游戏。
最高能达到4K 144帧。
延迟也很低
我用了游戏远程之后。
还真有一个视觉小说游戏。
叫人狼村之谜
就是用它来完成的。
因为手机上不是很方便安装。
我远程操作就可以了。
而且它对网速的要求。
这种视觉游戏就不是特别高。
躺在被窝里
你直接连着电脑
就可以玩电脑游戏了。
这些是有远程提供的。
一些小功能非常实用。
最后总结几个
我觉得最实在的点。
第一
它是免费的
而且是真免费
它不是说有性能阉割。
功能阉割
没有
它也没有会员
没有广告弹窗
所以如果之前
你实现这些功能
没有用到游戏远程。
完全值得试一下
第二
画质和延迟却是过硬。
毕竟它是网易的团队在做。
而且用的就是玩家们。
游口接杯的
游游加速器的技术。
大家一听到游游
很多游戏玩家都
第一反应是游游加速器。
那这个技术
用在游游远程上了。
那就说明游游远程的技术。
是有底子的
它用的P2P
直连加全球专网接点。
第三
系统支持非常全
刚才也说了
Windows Mac。
手机端的LS安卓。
它都有
以上这些
当然也不光是我
一个人的感受
大家真的可以去小红书。
去X翻一翻
不同用户的评价
夸他的人相当多
我还看到一个说法。
挺有意思
甚至可以说
是他们用过网易
最好的一个产品
如果感兴趣
可以到Shownotes。
了解一下
那关于游游远程
我们说到这
我们今天
既然聊到了小红书。
我们就接着聊聊
移动互联网时代的社区。
最主要的
上一期我们预告过了。
有两家
我们从第一家
开始聊
我们来到第一回
毛文超1985年。
武汉出生
他从小
也是那种别人家的孩子。
武汉一中毕业
03年考上上海教大。
在上海教大学机械电子。
07年毕业的时候。
同时拿到了麦肯西和贝恩。
两家顶级咨询公司的offer。
很厉害了
最后去了贝恩
两年之后
加入贝恩资本
做私募股权投资
从贝恩票到贝恩
这两家贝恩
是同源的两家公司。
从贝恩资询
到了贝恩资本
后来贝恩资本
又公费
送他去美国斯塔夫杜安比亚。
你可以说
这整个职业经历
就是人中龙奉
接下去
公费去杜安比亚
安比亚多贵
尤其美国的
这是一个典型
华尔街经营的剧本。
但是2013年
毛文超弄丝剧本
因为什么？
这一年
移动互联网的浪潮来了。
毛文超等不及了
不行了
我得创业
必须自己干
但是创业我很难
为什么呢？
因为有一个现实问题。
前面说了
他是公费去斯塔夫杜安比亚。
总有得还钱
对
你走可以
你得把钱还来
得赔多少钱
一百万
你看看
13年7月
毛文超怒赔100万。
下海创业
多大的决心
你要这个故事也挺神奇的。
确实有些人说
那是毕业及失业
毕业白手开始创业。
毛文超是毕业负债开始创业。
负债买自由
毛文超的背景
说起来
在我们之前讲过的。
中国互联网故事里面。
在创业者里是比较少见的。
因为他不是说
从那种你腿子出身的。
比较接地气的
这个行业干起来的。
他自己还是从投行和。
资金领域做起来的。
另外还有一个有意思的事。
就是毛文超后来提到。
斯坦福对他的影响。
不光是让他学会了。
商业和管理
反而对创业去昧了。
怎么叫去昧呢？
不是说创业不好了。
创业好像不是那么？
大家想象的
他之前在电视
影视剧里看到的那些企业家。
多惊天动地
多破腐沉抽
多苦大仇深
一说到创业
就是那种
一定是特别性格的人。
才能创业
不是的
他在斯坦福
接触到的那些企业家。
和创业者
就是平常人
大家就觉得
创业只是一个
普通的职业选择
甚至就是一份工作而已。
毛文超就觉得
这个事好像可以搞。
降低了卖出
第一步的心理难度。
他不是什么？
多急事白脸的事
在斯坦福
毛文超还遇到过
snapchat的创始人之一。
艾文斯皮格尔
同学里边
还有后来去创业
做了instagram的。
很多硅谷大佬
日常都在学校受客。
所以他接触到了
这些人之后
慢慢的也能对
创业有一个更立体的认知。
所以产生了
刚才说的这种心态。
他决定要创业
甚至还有一个
在斯坦福留传承广的故事。
这个故事有点难变真伟。
但是也跟大家分享一下。
说在第一年的期末考试之前。
毛文超之前
一直是一好学生
所以学习成绩一直很好。
让他忽然收到了一封。
学校寄给
所有学生的公开信。
这个公开信里说
在斯坦福拿不到
毕业证的概率
比交通事故的概率还要低。
如果有哪一门考试。
拿了高分
我们提醒你
反思一下自己
之前毛文超就
原来我读书读傻了。
我应该把注意力
放在课本之外
学校就是这么鼓励你的。
学校这么强调的
斯坦福大学
我们之前在讲
硅谷神话这个系列的时候。
也多次提过
他不一定真发这个公开信。
但是就当年
真的可能是有
这种校园的气质的。
那做什么呢？
毛文超想了想
他毕业之后
工作和都安毕业的这些年。
一直在旅行
旅行的这些年
他已经去过20多个国家了。
他自己有一个深刻的感受。
就是旅游攻略很多。
但是很多旅游攻略。
在当时还处于那种。
大家都同志化太严重。
而且提到的那几个点。
还是我们之前说的。
去上海就看东方明珠。
去北京就看天安门。
关于旅游里面
购物的这个信息
非常匱乏
就几乎不会提到
去哪儿买东西的
就看到这么一个小市场了。
2012年
毛文超的父母
当时准备去美国旅行。
想要采购一些东西。
他上网就搜
美国在哪儿买东西。
什么东西好
结果搜不明白
搜不到都没有
但是这是一个说法。
这是促使
他接下去
创业方向的一个说法。
一个痛点其实
另一个说法
这个idea
不是来自于毛文超。
是来自于他的合作伙伴。
叫渠方
他跟渠方一起调研。
然后毛文超自己一开始想的。
项目是什么呢？
做餐饮
做餐饮行业
帮用户在线排队
和定位的
这么一个软件
这个今天很成熟了。
就是当中点评
现在用户找餐厅
不好找
找到之后也需要排队。
这个餐厅在什么地址。
什么之类的
我可能有一个
POI的这么一个产品。
当时这么想的
完成最后100米的问题。
但是刚开始去做调研。
就发现很困难
在一开始
那个时候的餐厅老板。
接受程度非常低
所以一开始
也就没有起步了
没有正式起步
而在这个版本里面。
说的是毛文超和渠方。
在上海的田子坊
看项目
就当时看了一些
线下项目的时候
渠方表示
女性出国旅游的时候。
要花大量的时间
研究去哪儿购物
所以出去旅行
购物这个市场
是非常值得做的
这是另一个版本
所以说这个原始的火苗。
到底是合伙人A来的。
还是合伙人B来的。
有不同说法
当然也可能是
他们讨论出来的吧？
不知道
既然说到渠方了
也提一句
渠方是毛文超的老乡。
老乡也是武汉人
他是85或者84年出生的。
跟毛文超还是同龄人。
中学的时候
在武汉外国语学校读了六年。
在校期间
也一直积极参加活动和竞赛。
后来被保送进入
北京外国语大学
读的是新闻传播专业。
渠方是06年7月毕业的。
所以比毛文超
还要早一年毕业
大学毕业之后
进入德国媒体集团。
贝塔斯曼
在贝塔斯曼
后来还担任过
营销部的主管
两年之后
渠方到一家公司叫做。
We Know Culture公司。
管理公司旗下的一家。
全资挪威实体
在上海和武汉的
多个业务单位
具体他在We Know Culture。
做什么呢？
我搜了一下
没有太多记载
你大概可以理解
这家公司
做的就是跟品牌营销。
公关策划
线下展览
这些活动等等
有关系的一家公关公司。
或者叫文化公司
这个今天也很常见了。
说到这也要提一句。
渠方和毛文超的很多经历。
都是通过大量的
间接信息拼凑出来的。
这个和其他的互联网。
创业者不太一样
尤其你像马云和雷军这种。
光自己记录
自己讲的故事
就非常多了
有很多公开表达
但是刚才我们说的。
毛文超和渠方这些信息。
很多都是通过
非常计较干达的信息拼凑出来的。
比如说渠方的
比较明确的信息
是从小鹏汽车的官网里面。
找出来的
小鹏汽车的董事会成员里面。
因为他是小鹏的独立董事。
所以对独立董事
有这么一个个人建立。
才能找出来这些东西。
那毛文超和渠方是怎么认识的呢？
由于信息比较匱乏。
也有很多个版本
晚点在访问一些相关人士之后。
给出的版本是
他们在大学期间的。
一次校外活动当中认识的。
因为两个人是老乡。
毕业之后又都在上海工作。
有很多兴趣爱好比较相似。
比如说他们都很喜欢吃。
找一些非常好吃的餐厅。
出去经常打火
旅行 购物
很早就成为了朋友。
有的版本说他们是在美国认识的。
有的版本说他们是通过朋友。
和同事关系认识的。
等等
反正就是不同版本。
把各种可能性都辨历了。
但背后有一点是很确定的。
就是他们爱好相似。
而且是老乡
这个关系让他们走得比较近。
后来毛泽东决定创业的时候。
渠方在公司也待不住了。
打工也打不下去了。
两个人就商量
做点事吧？
做点吧？
2013年两个人先后辞职。
开始融资和组建公司。
在上海创办了这家公司。
这家公司叫做
行营信息科技公司。
开始做海外购物攻略。
就是他们之前决定的那个方向。
行营
这个也非常有武汉特色。
他们是武汉老乡
这个名字来自于
武汉东湖的行营阁。
据说是两个人在东湖。
湖边散步的时候
咱们就叫行营吧？
合防营销请徐行那个吗？
营唱的营行走的营。
就确定了这个名字。
说到东湖
我个人还是非常喜欢东湖。
每次去武汉
都会顺着武大逛一逛东湖。
它就是武大东门出去。
就是东湖
虽然说公司名是武汉风阁的。
但是他们一开始办公室。
在上海复兴西陆
无同区的那边的一间老宅。
一开始是很有上海特色的。
上海起家
这个照片是多年之后。
他们俩回到导师
创业的那个小办公室。
留下了一张合影
有点寻找初心的意思。
俩人都是穿着牛仔裤加白蹄。
很有学生感
这个房子能看得出来。
它比较老旧了
屋子应该办公室空间。
也不是特别大
最早做的这款产品。
也很体现互联网产品的MVP精神。
就是能用就行
我能用我就先上线。
所以它第一个版本。
既然要做海外旅行购物。
具体是什么形态呢？
当地购物攻略
它做的就是一个PDF文档。
就是做了一个攻略。
没有做App
这就是最符合MVP思路的。
我先看看
这个PDF有没有人看。
验证需求
到底有没有现实的存在意义。
最早做的PDF文档。
是中国香港等地知名的。
购物地点和店铺信息。
就给你做这么一个手册。
毛文超和渠方
亲自撰写了美国那边的旅游购物攻略。
又找了一圈的同事。
朋友同学
给他们帮忙撰写
第一批产品就是
七份不同国家和地区的PDF攻略。
当时还找了一个人帮忙来排版。
这个排版的朋友
后来也加入小红书。
成了小红书的第三号员工。
是后来小红书的产品负责人邓超。
帮他们做了排版
为什么呢？
因为这个邓超是设计师。
他是建筑设计师
但他就帮他们做了文字的排版。
图文的排版
毛文超还找到他在斯坦福的同学。
帮忙转稿
这个同学叫做丁玲。
丁玲也加入小红书了。
15年加入之后
他的画名就成了
今天也大名鼎鼎的柯南。
柯南现在是小红书的总裁。
说到画名
毛文超的画名叫新史。
渠方的画名叫木兰。
邓超的画名叫阴木。
全部都是东蛮人物。
这倒是还是很能体现。
一个企业文化
组织文化的
但是确实有不少朋友。
应该熟悉
小红书里面也是用画名的。
渠方的木兰
确实取自于花木兰。
花木兰是迪士尼
第一次用中国形象。
拍动画电影
今天的篇尾曲
那这一套
PDF格式的文档很自然的。
他们就想
我要几个名
几个什么名
因为中国之前
就一直有红宝书的说法。
特殊时期
不是红宝书
后来各个行业
就沿用了这个说法。
各种红宝书
我记得我们上中学。
反正就有单词红宝书。
考研的时候有考研红宝书。
当时李扬疯狂英语。
疯狂英语也有红宝书。
所以他们很自然的。
就给这份材料
起名叫小红书
出境购物攻略
就开始小红书都不是个app。
它就是购物攻略的。
这么一个名字
找到这么个意象
但是后来我看到
有一些分析事后分析说。
为什么叫小红书
因为斯坦福的主题色。
学校主题色是红色。
但我觉得有点坚强了。
这有点坚强了
你何必用母校的主题色。
有点绕了
这个PDF发布出去之后。
效果还不错
一个月之后
团队上线了一个
PC论坛网站
先做的网站
这样大家就可以在上面。
去分享自己的购物心得了。
就讨论起来了
但是这个时候
你看它创业的时候。
就已经是
互联网已经兴起了。
所以就发现
在这个论坛上
沟通效率很低
不如直接弄个APP。
大家必须抓紧
做移动端了
所以做了APP
这个APP
第一个名字就叫
小红书出境购物攻略。
还是沿用那个名
九个字
早年的很多IP
都是直接这么起
今日头条什么？
搞笑图片都直接这么起。
一个名字占了半个屏幕。
正是因为从零开始。
他们就没有太多包袱。
所以一开始
就会做得更加接近。
移动互联网需要的那种形态。
就更加碎片化
传统的社区和论坛。
我们上期聊过
它是BBS形式的。
会存在一个什么问题呢？
迁移的时候
会直接把这个模式搬过来。
所以就是你会看到。
一条一条的
它那个整个浏览的方式。
就有点痛苦
UI交互整体设计。
其实不是那么适合移动端。
小红书一开始参考的。
就是移动互联网的风格。
简单来说
就有点像
inst那种风格。
instgram那种风格。
一张图片加几句话。
可以快速传播转发。
这个跟早期的微博。
是很像的一个逻辑。
App上线之前
其实小红书
已经在微博和公众号。
经营了自己的购物资讯账号。
这两个账号
已经有累计四万多的粉丝了。
那个时候的画像
已经很集中了
就是北上广深一线城市。
喜欢出镜游
海外购物
和使用iPhone的女性。
很具体了
那会儿
其实还没有考虑逆模式的事。
是吧？
没有
一开始创业
App刚上线的第一天。
获得了两千多个用户。
进入了iOS旅游类。
应用排行榜的前二十。
大家都很开心
很厉害了
这产品要起飞了
然后呢？
没过几天
下载量卡卡卡往下掉。
就跌破了几百了
本来以为是做火箭。
结果做的是穿天猴。
穿了一下就没了
二提脚
到上都爆了
再往后怎么增长呢？
大家很茫然
茫然之中
什么方法都试一试。
慢慢摸索
买书
增长黑颗
在微博上面
做做投放什么的
然后大年初四
渠方那个时候
正在参加一个投资方面的活动。
同事突然给他发消息说。
小红说挂了
他蒙了
怎么刚上线就挂了。
是因为人太多了
人太多
夫妻挤爆了
你看看这是为啥呢？
大年初四
长假出去玩的人多。
那个时候
出境游的需求就爆发了。
春节出境游
非常乐观
2014年4月
他们的用户注册量。
已经破百万
新增用户次日流存。
据说一度达到70%。
这开心思了简直
用了就停不下来
接下来
他们就商量说
咱得做大做强了
咱得继续努力了
做大做强的过程当中。
两个联合创始人
就产生了一些分歧。
想法不一样了
什么分歧呢？
毛文超和渠方想法不一样。
毛文超更想做产品。
什么意思
他更想做一个
海外商品的真实口碑平台。
你可以理解
有点像豆瓣
或者当中点评
像之前我们提到
豆瓣东西
这上面有个商品
海外你买这个药
围绕这个药的SKU。
在下面去做各种评论。
渠方更想围绕内容。
做论坛
就是像之前的论坛。
大家写笔记分享
不是说围绕商品本身的。
其实是做一些资源共享。
后来商量去
最后还是选择了
渠方的这个方向
更自由沟通的这个方向。
也就是今天我们看到的。
小龙叔这个笔记的方向。
然后写笔记分享这个事。
从一开始
分享在海外
去哪个商场
买东西
买什么东西
慢慢已经开始拓展。
到了更多领域
也就是这个时候
种草这个词
被小龙叔开始普及了。
看别人分享的时候。
觉得这个很有意思。
但是我现在可能不买。
我到时候去买
我到时候便宜的时候。
或者到时候
我去那个地方的时候。
去买
那个行为叫做拔草。
种草拔草
这个概念慢慢的
就开始兴起了
做的过程当中
小龙叔也得考虑一个问题。
就是像刚才小蕾说的。
怎么赚钱呢？
很早在2014年12月。
小龙叔就上线了福利社。
福利社是什么呢？
就是他自己的电商产品。
福利这个词
也是很有意思的
在当年也很有一个历史特色。
就是我给大家发福利了。
所以你在这就能买到。
我给大家发福利便宜。
或者说更优质的东西。
有点时代的流行语的那个味道。
本来你在我这儿
不是通过各种内容。
通过我们分享的
这些资源
种草吗？
拔草
你直接在这完成不就好了吗？
对
你不用出去了
或者说你没有条件出去。
这个其实跟我们之前提到的社区。
做商业化的逻辑
比如说豆瓣
做电影
做卖票
虎铺
做体育
做分销
也是类似的逻辑
单纯你做内容社区。
就只能靠贴广告赚钱。
但如果能跟产业有前观点的话。
你商业模式不就更稳重。
更成熟了吗？
那做电商
它就涉及到一个问题。
就得烧钱
它比你单纯的做一个内容产品。
就要贵多了
小红书当时有没有钱呢？
特别有钱
因为时间来到了14年。
14年又是我们说的一栋互联网。
热火烹油
到时候都是热钱的时候。
毛泳超创业
他就不是说纯白手出来创业的。
他其实是拿了融资在做的。
2013年10月。
他在美国
还没回国
就已经见到了徐晓平。
在美国跟徐晓平见面。
拿了真格基金的
几百万人民币的天使轮投资。
2014年6月
刚过半年
又拿到了A轮融资。
这次金沙江
创投也加入了
一共融了数百万美元。
15年6月金沙江。
和计员资本GTV。
再次投资数千万美元。
币轮
就过了一年半
已经拿了几千万了。
16年3月
又拿到了腾讯领头的。
1亿美元融资
一轮一轮的
都是翻着笨的上
那确实是不缺钱了。
2018年
拿到了阿里巴巴领头的。
3亿美元融资
在2018年
小红书已经估值
超过30亿美元了。
在当年是
想当当的第一梯队的独角兽。
所以你说回来
前前后后这么多轮融资。
但要是很充足的
但是
大家肯定是有感觉的。
你说小红书
今天自营电商
做得好不好
好像
没有印象中那么好。
这我们就说回来
当时福利社怎么做的。
福利社不是说
只是做一个
卖商品的界面
它是纯自营的电商。
完全自营
自营跨境电商
自己兼保税仓
自己采购
自己发货
全流程
全部自建
可拉是不是也是这样。
对
跟可拉很类似
面积
当时
就是自建的
保税仓的面积
在全国跨境电商当中排名第二。
在海外有20多个仓库。
武汉光客服团队
都有300多人
这就是可拉这个
可拉比他晚
可拉要比他晚的
这就残亏了
你看当时
前几期刚提起小红书来的时候。
当年肯定是
经历过这个阶段的。
明显的就是忘了
他开始做过这个事。
当时我就不记得
而且你从叙事上来讲。
你拿到当时的时间点。
大家觉得超级顺
就是根本
找不到更顺的商业化的方式了。
你小红书你做
跨境电商的攻略了吧？
你跨境电商攻略
大家看了这个东西。
种草好了
我直接在你平台上。
还能买得到
太对了
太顺了
没毛病
而且中间
刚开始他们做的
确实也挺顺的
电商团队最早提出来了。
叫八字真言
怎么说
就是每个商品
都要有八个字以内。
讲明白的产品卖点。
比如说最早推这个。
戴森吹风机
当时的戴森
可能认知还不是那么多。
大家不是特别了解。
他就说
吹风机中的爱马士。
大家一看
大概有一个了解了。
正好八个字
一开始推的时候
包括卡西欧自拍神器。
规交系列银
抗氧化丸等等这种。
新奇的玩意
在当时推的都非常成功。
上线一年
小红书电商的GMV突破3亿。
当时是什么江户地位。
国内GMV增速最快的。
电商平台
没有之一
那显然空间太大了。
那时候没有屏多多。
那个时候阿里
这个移动化也是刚起步。
大家当然知道
它是电商头把交椅。
但是不觉得小红书。
就没有能打的
没有能打的入场圈。
或者是传票
很有机会的
2015年双十一期间。
小红书还上了IOS总绑第一。
2016年
小红书电商用户
从2400万上涨到5000万了。
太好了
当时小红书
大家的认知就是
你做的好
那一来就是中国电商巨头。
这不是说闹着玩的。
但是福利社
小红书自行电商水下的一些东西。
很多朋友是没有看得到的。
行业里的
很多人也没有看到。
因为小红书的电商战略方向。
虽然它不是说
我就要做最贵
但是它肯定不是要做最便宜的。
它要做评价
甚至有的时候
还有点溢价
这是毛泼潮刚开始定下来的。
一个大的策略
也就是说
它的商品价格
就是跟海外含税价完全一致。
但是你要想这个价格能不能打呢？
在后面就面临一个巨大的危机。
因为2016年
小红书电商做到巅峰的日子。
就是拼好货和拼多多。
开始做的日子
完全两个方向上给它再拉扯呀？
这一年拼好货和拼多多。
双双达到1亿元的GMV。
我们之前讲拼多多的时候。
提到过
中国电商行业将会有巨变。
那小红书你既然价格不是能打穿。
你能不能靠别的特性。
比如说你保证品
你保品牌
能不能保障呢？
不能
你有自己的保税仓。
你有自己的采购渠道。
依然不能
还是会出问题
你哪怕拿到官方授权。
要求各种资质
也没办法保证获真价实。
为什么我们之前说。
德务那套逻辑
最后大家相对能接受。
你必须所有人
你哪怕是官方
所谓的官方渠道发货。
你也得先发到我这个平台上。
我跟你做见真呢？
为什么呢？
是因为
这就是电商平台的老大难问题。
授权书可以造假
而且本来这个也是拍照上传。
我就随便拍照
造个假上传
几百块钱
咸鱼上买一个
甚至有一些商家渠道。
他会在各种活动上邀请品牌方。
跟品牌方合影
这个照片是真的
但是他就会说
我是官方授权商
可以直接拿到
其他地方来所谓的附用了。
这种东西
他的造假跟过去
我们说有些商人造假说。
我这有特殊渠道
我认识是谁
我跟他有合影
插球不多的
反正我花钱能蹭一些活动。
我就能拿到这些照片。
所以在这个方面
小红书福利社在当时。
并没有留下那么好的口碑。
他也很艰难做的
另外不光拼多多拼好货。
天猫也开始做
天猫国际的自营业务。
网易考拉也开始做。
自己的海外业务
这两个平台
人家做得更专业
人家做得更扎实
所以相当于他没把标签打出来。
没有什么不可替代性。
根据一个小红书
电商员工的回忆说。
那个时候
本来供应商来上海。
他就直接来上海了。
后来他们来上海
他得先到杭州
杭州败完码头
我们是简胜的
你想象一下就知道了。
杭州这边网易阿里。
这两大巨头的先败完码头。
所以渠道之战
小红书占不到太多优势。
而价格战期间
小红书的用户
更再次大量流失
2016年
小红书跨境电商
在中国的市场分额是6.5%。
两年之后
跌到了4.3%
一路再往下走
天谋国际和网易迅速崛起。
占据了50%的市场分额。
基本上这一场仗
也就差不多打到这了。
半路杀出的程亚金。
还是很厉害
另外有一点
小红书长期
他的组织文化风格。
的确不太适合干这种。
线下所谓的家引号。
又脏又累的活
我们之前讲拼多多的时候。
也讲过公司企业文化。
显然和一个做内容的公司。
就不一样了
比如说当时小红书。
扩张太快
内部管理非常混乱。
根据一位全员工的回忆。
有一个采购助理
述职回报的时候
他还不是说日常回报。
他是我自己要升职。
我的回报的时候
领导才知道
他自己半年
采购了多少钱的商品。
采购了多少钱
1.5亿的商品
这个权力太大了
当时管理称说
你半年花了1.5亿。
那你现在
月销售额是多少
这个采购助理说
怎么着也有个100万吧？
管理层当时就是
楼下买了阵楼
我的天哪
你想象一下
就这么一个切片
你就能看得出来
当时内部管理多混乱。
你日常的周报
日报还有什么各种会议。
你居然都发现不了。
这么一个数字
你也是我们
可能谈过多次
很多公司什么快速扩张。
丢亏欺贾的阶段
对
所以说
虽然大家还是提起阿李。
提起网易
来对他们的组织
颇有为辞
以来说
阿李在电商方面的运营。
还是足够精细的
它不会出这么大的问题。
2017年小红书电商建威。
陷入停滞
保持在100亿左右。
就不太变化了
同时监管部门
又有一个巨大的变化。
有一个新的税收政策。
过去跨京商品的优惠税。
彻底没有了
然后公司内部
就在讨论
到底怎么办
咱是抱着这100亿。
坚持不放
再继续试一试
还是说
就是放弃掉这一点。
因为少前总要有个头。
之前小红书这边
在这几年哪怕
福利社这边
电商做的
一直非常激进的过程当中。
它也一直跟社区
相对保持隔离
现在的第一态不业。
依然还是社区
而且社区里面的倒流。
也一直比较截至
没有说
到处都给它塞在广告位。
或者说露出
让大家都去买东西。
社区这边保护的
还算是比较好
那接下来
要决策的就是
你看电商
有点撑不住了
咱是拗印电商
把社区这部分
这些流量
这些价值倒给电商。
扶一扶电商
还是说
咱要么电商就不要了。
咱就坚持做社区吧？
到底是把所有的毛。
划下来
烧了取暖
还是我干脆
是
反正这个时候
是一个很重要的
战略决策
这是所谓
历史转折的一年
对于小红书来说
同时小红书
也在考虑自己的
退路的问题
甚至已经在跟
巨头接触了
据说当时阿里
是要花几百亿
直接按照估值
买下它来的
你看
可能是坐在
考拉前面的
本来可以
当时组织
也遇到很多问题
很多高管都离职了。
公司的市企大受影响。
2018年初
电商负责人离职
物流负责人离职
包括电商负责人
简一的
就是它下面的
很多高管都离职
电商负责人楼一林。
这位还是毛文超的。
上海交大的同届校友。
他们是很多年了
这种老朋友
老同学
最后也离职了
这么有新人关系的离职。
对毛文超冲击也很大。
也就是在2018年初。
小红书最终决定
全面拥抱社区
社区还是咱小红书的核心。
咱不能伤毛
那就选择另一条路。
就不往那个冷的地方。
继续走
我退回来
我去热带了
在这几个月
毛文超为了稳住军心。
在公司内也反复提到。
马斯克的第一性原理。
咱们第一性还是社区。
咱还是想到这个根本上。
咱们小红书本质是个什么公司。
到这算是小红书发展的。
第一阶段
经过跌宕起伏
电商那边阶段性放弃了。
那确定是社区
作为核心之后
公司开始讨论
咱社区咱也得加把劲。
咱社区咱也得增长。
内容上看看
要做点什么新的东西。
怎么增长
小红书也开始尝试。
高举高打的事情了。
小红书在这几年投放了。
爱奇艺的综艺
偶像练习生
结果效果非常好
这个综艺在上线之前。
大家预期不高
上线之后
正好也赶上了那几年综艺。
火爆的年份
大量的女性粉丝
开始注册小红书
后来小红书又投放了。
在一开始
还没有那么火的创造101。
再加上后来的各种综艺的投放。
效果都很好
还有社区层面的价值。
慢慢显现出来了
范冰冰 林云 张宇奇。
这些人的账号都被曝光了。
他们都不是官方
主统邀请运营的
就是他们自己
觉得小红书这样是挺好的。
我想开一个号
在这个时期
小红书的社区氛围。
也是比较温和的
比今天还是温和一些的。
尤其是比当时的微博。
微博上已经很难正常聊天了。
所以很多人到小红书去交流。
然后明星
完全可以自由表达在那个时候。
所以很多明星是很喜欢。
在上面开帐号跟大家聊天的。
这算是小红书第一次出圈。
因为那个时候
你如果作为明星
你在微博上提一个什么东西。
大家就会说
你这个又炫富了
你这个又买个什么东西。
出来说
但是你在小红书上说。
我买了个什么东西。
大家都会问在哪买的。
这个东西还挺好的。
怎么怎么样
但是聊天的氛围是不太一样的。
而小红书在这个阶段。
做得非常重要的
也很准确的一个运营动作。
就是刻意去营销感。
去明星化
明星来了
当然欢迎
但是我不是说非常极致的欢迎。
我就让明星全部占了大头。
让内容的大头
变成都是讨论明星。
围绕明星的
不是这样的
这就会挤压普通用户的创作空间。
像现在的微博
可能就是有点这个感觉。
它更多的变成
大家追星的一个平台了。
而UGC内容和KOC内容。
一直都是小红书的。
核心差异化的价值。
UGC
我们之前反复提到过。
就是普通用户生产的内容。
KOC就是
关键消费领袖
关键顾客领袖
所以再到后来
前两年有一个
有争议的事件
就是小红书给非常多的用户。
很可能是权量铺式了。
那个通知说
赵路斯来小红书了。
那个活动
被很多人批评
包括身边很多互联网同业者。
也非常吃惊
就是小红书为什么会。
这样做
当时很多网友说
别叫小红书了
叫小路书
这也说明说
大家对小红书
之前那个坚持的关注度。
2017年小红书。
战略上全面转型社区之后。
商业化的重点
就不放在电商上了。
放在广告体系上
2019年社区电商。
升级为品牌号部门。
广告主引入社区生态。
跟达人对接
相当于就靠这些
达人接商单去做合作了。
2020年初
小红书开始做直播电商。
这个电商当然也还是电商。
但是它逻辑不一样。
不是跨境电商了
当然直播电商
它也是更多的
自然生长的一个方式。
没有特别高举高打。
后来相对破圈
是在2023年双十一期间。
明星张晓慧董杰
在小红书开直播
当时直播单场
销售额能做到破译。
这是比较历史性的一个节点。
确实很破圈的事
说回来2019年初。
小红书的日和突破千万。
但是他们内部复盘。
也比较清醒
就是复盘来复盘去。
找个原因是什么？
很难说清楚
有很多主动动作
但是你很难说
哪个主动动作
直接导致了什么结果。
因素太复杂了
自然流量
到底在这里面占比多少。
也很难讲
你当然也有可能
就是这几年
移动互联网的环境好了。
或者经济环境好了。
大家消费医院高了。
所以来看小红书的人变多了。
都是完全有可能的。
而这一年的增长
也给小红书带来
一些严重的问题
也就是小红书
第一次爆发比较破圈的。
平台治理的事件
2019年7月底。
南方都市报
深度调查曝光
小红书很多笔记
在引流寿脉
违近衣美真迹
大量的无资质邮衣。
这个邮方医生
主要靠小红书获可。
不光这些非法行医。
还包括大量的
软广灰产
烟草擦边射黄
等等的内容
小红书上太多了
国内的安卓应用商店。
几乎立刻全部下架小红书。
小红书也立马启动。
全站排查
一直到10月份
安卓端采在
各大应用商店恢复上架。
后来2020年
也爆发过
比较有争议的事件。
就是名媛和炫富事件。
当时自媒体人李中二。
卧底上海名媛群
半年之后
发了长文
揭露名媛的精致生活。
你看说是名媛
其实都是拼单
大家习惯名媛了
虽然他叫名媛
但我们就爱名媛说了。
就是说社交名媛
那个意思
社交名媛
整天出入高端场合的。
但实际上都是
大家十几个上二十个人。
去拼单
买个酒店房间
大家轮流在那拍照片。
这个肯定很多人
都还有印象当年这个事。
同年还出现了
《凡尔塞》文曲
《凡尔塞》也是从小红书。
和博主这边出现的。
以及大家在小红书上。
对炫富博主的各种干的讨论。
也是这个期间变多的。
2021年还发生了。
滤镜景点翻车的一系列事件。
很多照片拍的滤镜。
加得过强
导致很多网友
跟着这个照片
到了现场之后
发现不是那么回事。
你要拍出这个照片。
你得找非常雕钻的角度。
真的一个角度
拍出来是东方小巴黎。
包括那个滤镜家的颜色。
也根本不是那么回事。
当时也引起了很多争议。
所以你看这每一年发生的。
各种有争议的平台治理的事件。
也都让小红书特别警惕。
在平台治理上下了很多功夫。
你不能让平台
变成一个炫富平台。
也不能让平台变成。
一个虚假的作秀的平台。
你这样离大家的
真实生活越来越远之后。
大家就不愿意在这发帖子。
发笔记了
这又是那句话
不能走得太远
忘了为何出发吗？
在这个阶段
小红书慢慢的
从当年大家寄予
厚望的一个电商方面。
可以跟这些主流
巨头一拼的平台
慢慢又回到了一个。
看起来不闻不火的小公司。
小平台
普遍觉得是不是也就这样了。
但是赛翁是马
燕之飞浮
这个治理消除了风险之后。
正好赶上了一个好时机。
之前要是没出这些。
淋漓碎碎的事
可能不会做太多平台治理。
后面反而还挺麻烦的。
为什么呢？
正好来到了
全国人民闭门在家的。
这个时间段
你看20年
互联网产品
很多都是在这几年迅速爆发的。
包括抖音
包括其他很多产品。
小红书在这个阶段。
从单纯的
早年女性购物的社区。
已经迅速发展成了。
包括菜谱家居
装修等等
生活方式的一个社区了。
这些生活方式
从疫情期间
它又引入了大量男性用户。
所以在这几年
男女的比例
也在不断地调整
发生变化
也是在同时期
公司正式宣布
我们也要拗印视频。
从各部门抽调人员组成。
视频团队
算法运营资源
都在向视频倾斜
2020年8月
小红书推出了视频号。
视频时长
也直接延长到了
最高15分钟
现在甚至延长到了更长。
你可以在小红书上。
听
特别完整的播客了。
像前段时间
大家也能在上面
看到执行小酒馆
他们的视频播客的数据。
也都是很好的
我们俩录得最长的。
也快接近一个小时了。
后来小红书
也还是一直有坚持的。
他并不是说
其他平台都在做视频。
所以我也就做视频。
其他平台做什么？
我就跟着做了
比如说
他也坚持
没有把双列
改成单列抖音式的那种。
沉浸式刷臂机的那种形式。
但是幸亏没改
改了就变成另一个抖音了。
变成另一个抖音
你跟抖音就没法竞争了。
肯定是竞争不过的。
双列相当于是
更有利于用户去做筛选。
让用户有更多的选择权。
我看到封面
我看到这个话题
是不是感兴趣
我再决定要不要点进去。
小红书在这个过程当中。
运营动作会比以前多一些。
比如我们经常能看到的。
之前录营火的时候。
路冲 飞盘
City Walk。
这些火的时候
小红书都会主动做一些动作的。
这些小众内容都是有差异化的。
这也是小红书官方做的一些选择。
我不是说火的内容。
有流量的内容我都推。
而是在其他平台你可能讨论比较少。
见得比较少的内容。
我去做一些差异化。
另外可能也有一无一。
能塑造自己的所谓的调性。
对 调性就是很重要的。
一个差异化的方面。
小红书在这方面是非常清醒的。
你想你如果全都做。
其他平台都有的最大众的内容。
那你去每个平台看。
都有可以看的
但是如果说这些小众内容。
大家想到露营
想到City Walk。
我想要去找一个小众的店。
我只能在小红书看。
它就慢慢会形成一个。
很重要的品牌认知。
我就更愿意来这个平台。
比如说
后来在小红书
能刷到各种各样小众的宠物笔记。
比如你在其他平台。
猫 狗 鸟 鱼都能搜到。
但是你要是搜西艺 杨夺 甲虫。
你要是想个西过虫。
我在小红书是能刷到的。
但我估计淘宝也有。
但我是在小红书刷到的。
卖西过虫的
那是卖
就是你刷到
这个东西还能养
以及说这个东西怎么养。
它成奇奇的
很多时候在小红书。
你能刷到很多这种经验和笔记。
所以慢慢的小红书。
通过这些运营手段。
它形成了一个流量。
非常大的兴趣社区。
这点也很重要
而且它在吞掉
其他垂直兴趣社区的空间。
就在这几年
就在疫情期间
小红书崛起了
这几年疯狂地往上穿。
而往上穿的时候
就很容易被盯上了。
之前做电商
那是被阿里和网易盯上。
现在做内容
被谁盯上呢？
2021年初
小红书日火
已经冲破5000万。
成为全国增长
最快的互联网产品之一。
这个时候
真正从一个当年
第三第四梯队的小读教授。
已经变成了
中国最大的社区之一了。
年底小红书完成了。
5亿美元融资
固执达到200亿美元。
投资方
包括淡玛西
腾讯 阿里等等
被谁盯上了呢？
被抖音盯上了
这个时候
小红书正式成为抖音的。
在整个团队内部的。
头号公敌
我们就是要
正面去打小红书
要成立打书办
为什么要成为
头号公敌呢？
因为出现了一个
非常重要的信号
这个信号就是
抖音的团队发现
用户开始刷小红书了。
以前大家用小红书的方式。
主要是搜
但是现在已经变成搜加刷了。
这就很危险了
什么概念的搜
那是说明
我有需求的时候
我再打开看一看
平常我还是刷抖音的。
对 但是我如果
有没有需求
我都愿意打开
随便刷一刷
那就会挤抖音的空间了。
这就是完全不一样的。
一个场域了
一个赛道了
所以当时
抖音的负责人张南。
直接在内部发起了L专项。
这个L
没有特别的含义
他就是选了一个字母。
这些没用过的一个。
随便选
不是说按字母说去排一下吗？
算是排下来的
这内部也有一些
其他的项目
排到L了
他们当时很疑惑
抖音自己的数据
已经长得飞快了
几乎在那几年作为流量黑洞。
已经把中国的内容没借。
它都不光是什么？
传统意义上的
视频网站
微博这种社交媒体没借。
它吞掉了电视台
吞掉了电台
大家都有这个印象。
抖音是全吞的
怎么小红书还能投席起来呢？
小红书还在往上走。
而且中间
字节也去谈了
字节曾经跟小红书谈过。
要用200亿美元。
收购小红书
直接按照小红书当时的大致估值。
小红书没有同意
后来张南亲自代队。
在抖音上线了图文专区。
直接打小红书
后来甚至还把一级。
同城Type
同城入口的Type。
直接改为重草Type。
就叫重草了
但效果还是一般
小红书还是继续增长。
那么问题就来了
这是为什么呢？
为什么呢？
还是得说到社区这件事。
我们其实上期简单聊过。
社区是围绕人和人的关系的。
但是抖音它更多的像。
它就像一个电视台。
它是一个内容平台。
它是个媒体平台
它关系性没有那么强。
它形成这种平台
团队要做的方向
内部运营的方式
产品的结构都很大的不一样。
举个例子
小红书在2017年。
团队有一个核心指标叫CES。
用户参与分
什么意思呢？
就可以简单理解
是各种互动的数据的总和。
包括点赞 收藏 评论 转发 关注等等。
这些用户行为
把这些用户行为的数据结合起来。
再通过不同的权重。
去做出一个分支来。
这个权重里面
收藏是一个很关键的指标。
在抖音这些短视命名男上。
通常来说不会特别在意收藏。
因为它是不太好讲的。
清楚的指标
你让用户都收藏了。
它和直接能带来的。
商业价值之间的关系。
不是那么好讲
但是收藏
我们也都能想象到。
它能鼓励很多
所谓有价值的内容。
也就是所谓有用的内容。
有用是小红书官方也好。
或者说大家讨论起小红书来说。
最重要的一个社区的定位。
这在它早期的社区品牌形成上。
非常关键的一个概念。
理解有用这一个词。
你就可以说能更好地理解小红书了。
大体理解一下
你同样是一百条内容。
你要是逼所谓的有效性的话。
小红书的有效性要高于抖音。
有用
就是有用
因为有效的话
它可能还是有点抽象。
比如说我笑得很开心。
一种内容
或者说我看了之后。
我觉得我产生了
其他的一些情绪波动。
这些都不算是有用。
但是你有用
单拆出来其中的一类内容。
据说有用这个词
是他们最早第一版。
PDF上线之后收集到了反馈。
这里面大量的
不是说排版真精致。
这个文档做的真漂亮。
大量的用户反馈
都是说这个PDF真有用。
所以他们一开始就有这个意识。
在很多内容平台
用户时长是非常重要的。
一个指标
甚至是第一指标
因为用户使用的时间。
越长就有价值
这个在抖音
一定也是抖音的
最重要的指标之一。
你算一个简单的数学体。
就知道你在的时间越长。
你转化力相同的情况下。
你显然给平台创造的价值就更多。
但是
根据小红书的产品经理。
宋健回忆的
毛文超认为
小红书最核心的指标。
不是用户的使用时长。
但是后来也是小红书。
很重要的一个指标。
但是最重要的
毛文超认为不是
而他认为的核心指标。
人均搜索量代表的跟有用。
它也是一一贯之的。
就是信息价值
用户时长代表的是上引。
上引不是信息价值。
你上引多了
他可能反而你耽误用户。
做别的事
当然毛文超
从小红书的这个角度理解的。
重点就是做有用
做搜索
所以后来我们也能看到小红书。
确实他的内容
相当程度上
也替代了大量的搜索引擎。
根据2023年的一个数据。
小红书用户打开的。
首个动作是搜索的占比。
已经超过了60%。
也就意味着现在一个用户打开。
的确是要搜一些东西的时候。
打开的场景会更多。
哪怕不看这个总体数据。
大家就感受自己
在使用过程当中的变化。
以前搜索主要去哪。
咱们就说一动作
这两年搜索你主要去哪。
小红书的这个比例。
是不是越来越高了。
就有一个感受了
有一个视角
就是说小红书非常清醒的自己。
知道自己想要什么？
我想要的就是
我要创造社会价值。
我要做有用的平台。
让大家获取真是有用的信息。
但是这个是一个
八高的一个说法
另一个视角就是
小红书可能也比较清醒的知道。
他要是直接跟自己。
直接竞争那个所谓娱乐化的。
所谓大家杀世间的那种需求。
那可能也没法去竞争。
所以只能做这种差异化的内容。
因为抖音就是在有用这方面。
他就做的一直是比较吃力。
从另一个层面
但是这不是他的目的。
就是我能想到的
大家在生产内容的时候。
用了更多的心思
也会对这个平台
有更多的感情投入。
所以最后形成的一个结果。
就是我们现在
大家想象一下
自己打开抖音的时候。
你想的是什么？
你想它就是我打发一下这个时间。
我希望看到的是
好玩有意思的内容。
你在这里面
可以间歇的刷到一些有用的。
但是你可能没有那么有耐心去阅读。
尤其你刷到图文
我的看视频
看着热闹闹的
突然看到一个图文。
你就没有耐心去看这些文字。
这就是所谓的产品新制。
和品牌新制
它是类似的
段永平不是老爷说。
茅台做什么？
这个品牌就完了
那做啤酒
一做啤酒
这就完了
你相当于消耗过去。
大家对你的高认知。
去卖一个更便宜的产品。
最后你就会消耗
这个就会出大问题。
所以现在抖音
大家已经形成共识。
我打开之后
就是为了好玩
当我看到你教我做个菜。
我当然也可以看一眼。
但是我可能耐心
就会比打开小红书的时候。
小很多
现在你既然打开小红书的时候。
是为了搜一些东西。
是知道这些笔记里面。
有很多有用的东西。
那心态就不一样
当然虽然说
从社区层面抖音
很难抢小红书的地盘。
但是小红书自己
依然要面临要解决的问题。
还是前面说到的问题。
就是商业化的问题。
毕竟前面说
全面拥抱社区
拥抱社区之后怎么赚钱呢？
还是靠不上电商的事。
2018年小红书做线下了。
他退出了自己的生活方式品牌。
有光
要有光
那个有光
叫Redelight。
这个Redelight里面卖啥呢？
卖睡衣
卖床品
卖保温杯
卖刀具
锅 养生糊等等
萌益延伸线下店的即适感。
一模一样
它是ODM的路线。
三个月后
小红书又在上海
晋安大越城
开了新的一家
叫小红书之家
Red Home。
400多瓶
1000多个SKU。
加剧美妆服饰明星。
厨窗 水吧？
六个区
非常大的一个商场。
但是这些线下的尝试。
2020年前后
全都关掉了
说是他们一个
试验性的项目
那这个肯定是
不是特别成气候的。
在小红书
另外
2020年小红书。
毕竟前面说了
他自己不做了吗？
那怎么办呢？
就打开了笔记商品。
外链功能
可以直接链接到
阿里
其他的这些电商平台。
主要就是淘宝了
但是2021年7月。
关闭了外链全线
又开始做自行电商。
这是
这是当时很知名的。
一个事件
当时推出的电商平台。
叫小绿洲
小红书做的小绿洲。
2022年初
小红书电商负责人。
忽然宣布离职
根据前员工的表达。
就是公司对他做的。
很不满意
而组织层面
面临的问题
跟我们前面提到的。
问题也类似
他们确实在某些方面。
可以说跟我们上期讲的。
豆瓣很相似
比较有文科气质
会想很多
城市建设
社区维护的一些课题。
但是对于技术方面。
对于做一些
线下实业方面的一些事情。
没有其他的公司
那么有优势
而且组织上是非常动荡的。
它的组织上动荡到什么程度呢？
根据应该是财心媒体的报道。
小红书
每年
它这个跟阿里一样。
每年会给工作
满五年的员工
送一枚tifni的戒指。
2025年
有多少人拿到这枚戒指呢？
这个数据很有意思。
你猜一下
几千人当时
反正应该有大几千人。
小红书
那你这不是公布答案了吗？
不是 公司有大几千人。
公司有大几千人
呦
呆满五年的
当年发戒指的
还想往前去猜呢？
那你要这么说的话。
那我往几十去猜了。
八个人
哎呦 我天呐
呆过五年的
只有八个
当然不是说
所有呆过五年的是八个。
是那一年
那一年呆过五年的。
只有八个
缝伍的
只有那你就可以想象。
它这个稳定性
因为知道
知道它的流动性很大。
但是没想到一贯来说。
是这么大的
而且这个事
大家都就能想象
它就不是说体制内体制外。
外企国企还是什么？
你只要一个组织里。
流动性这么大
有一些之前领导
要做的事情
你后面就很难落实和执行。
它一定是反复推翻的。
不管是内部
还是跟他们沟通的外部人。
都会有这种反馈
2023年10月。
只做了一年多的小绿洲。
直接关闭
坚持了很多年的福利社。
其实是在这一年
彻底关闭的
小红书这些年方向上。
你就能看到它的漂浮不定。
明明之前说
我要奥运社区了
到后来还是
这不行
不能放外面
又要做自营
然后自营这个
又做了一两年
又关闭了
可以说商业化这个层面。
跟社区建设的两个部分。
真的是水深火热
完全不一样
整体的氛围截然不同。
社区争争日上
各方面都很乐观
男性用户变多
日活越活
疯狂增长
这次就不是二提角了。
都已经看着眼察
也抢不来这块肉
但是商业化角度来说。
你别说外界了
内部大家都有点迷糊。
也不知道在怎么办。
你确实着急
总得挣钱
2023年
公司再次转向
第三方电商
开始挂商品链接
这次的效果
一直坚持到现在
很多其他平台的商品。
迅速涌入
这也变成了小红书。
电商业务的主要组成。
不过哪怕电商
看起来终于阶段性。
放弃自营
看起来也有增长
但是跟我们之前讲。
豆瓣和虎谱
有一些社区的逻辑一样。
为什么小红书不放外链。
我们从消费者的角度来说。
你放了外面
买起来也方便
商品也全
你干嘛非要做自营。
利润太薄了
你相当于放外链
利润是很难支撑小红书。
去变成一个
它日常能支撑成本的。
这么一个商业化的方式的。
所以现在小红书的。
主要营收
你别看它第三方外链很热。
主要营收还是广告。
小红书的广告
跟其他平台广告
也不太一样
更多的是品牌营销渠道。
跟抖音这些平台
是有显著差别的
早些年新消费品牌。
活起来的时候
大家应该有印象
第一品牌
可以说是完美日记。
小红书那个时候
是完美日记最重要的渠道。
应该是没有之一
KOC这个概念
应该就是完美日记。
提出来
后来普及的
从比例
也能看出来
跟抖音的差别
小红书的营收
在2021年有三分之一。
来自蒲公英
蒲公英也就是
达人带货
我去做定制
都内容定制
而不是说
纯曝光的这个平台。
这个蒲公英
在抖音对标的是新图。
新图在字节整体营收中。
只占不到10%
一个是三分之一
一个是十分之一
小红书长期以来
三大蒲公英客户
分别是宝杰
亚式兰带和欧拉雅。
很多设施品牌
也都入住了
像LV 开云
爱马仕等等
都有自己的官方账号。
他们也入住抖音
你当然在抖音上
也都能找到账号
但是投放逻辑上
他们在品牌方面的。
很多预算
的确是更多放在小红书的。
而关注交易转化的。
很多效果营销
很多想要卖货的营销。
更多是放在抖音的。
这个也好理解
合逻辑
也合想象
所以总体来说
小红书今天
商业化尝试了这么多手段。
到今天为止
也还依然是
一家广告公司
而不是一家电商公司。
盈利的大头
来自于品牌广告
但你说回来
这个中草的生态位。
还是很占得住的
其他平台是抢不了。
它这个生意的
说到这我们再看看。
今天的小红书
今年小红书买下了。
世界杯的播放权
是为了进一步提高。
男性运户
行业现在的分析
有很多种
大家也评价不一
有的时候效果非常好。
是一场漂亮账
有的还是在保持质疑。
这个最后的结论
可能还得让子弹
再飞一会
等这个数据在沉淀沉淀。
看看走完了之后
能留下多少
现在小红书
你看它的产品功能。
和它的具体
到底是一个什么样的。
内容平台呢？
也很难表述了
因为也非常复杂了。
这个平台里面有长途文。
有语音评论
有播客有中视频
长视频等等
它不是一个简单的。
只有图文笔记的小平台了。
小红书现在的日和。
已经破译了
有一个第三方口径的统计。
是22年营收20亿美元。
23年营收37亿美元。
24年营收40亿美元。
25年营收60亿美元。
一路往上走
而在25年
净利润已经达到20亿美元了。
今年预计净利润
会到30亿美元
23年是小红书的盈利拐点。
所以这一路走来也不容易。
这几年一直在往上走的。
用户方面
刚才说了
它的日和破译
现在月和基本上是在4亿左右。
22年只有2亿
4年过去
已经涨到4亿左右了。
这个数字也有点印象。
30岁以下的用户占比65%。
整体是偏年轻的
女性用户和男性用户。
差不多是七三开
而根据最新的数据。
在男性用户这方面做的努力。
目前也看着没有白费。
男性用户现在是35.7%。
比22年提高了7个百分点。
这个跟伯克的听众分布。
还真挺接近的
也是三七分
从垂类看
小红书的内容
第一大垂类是美食。
第二食尚
第三二次元
第四游戏
你看
第32次元
你看二次元和游戏。
它就代表着
这个性别可能就会更加均衡了。
你说到美食时尚
整体上还是更偏女性一点。
一二线城市用户占比超过50%。
中高消费水平用户占比超过90%。
难受啊？
对 哪怕三四线城市。
基本上也都是稍微高消费一点的。
守着这些人
还是没把这个框挖出来。
对
还有一个数据挺有意思。
叫做8000元以上高价位。
手机持机人群
因为你能统计到这个设备。
用户的活跃用户规模破2亿了。
8000块以上的手机。
不然是不是越活
差不多能占一半的越活的话。
你说啥水平
就是能证明小红书用户的。
它有高净值
这也是一个
所有社区都面临的命题。
我的用户明明很有钱。
它怎么能
不给我花钱
让我多赚点钱
那关于小红书
小红书刚才说的很多逻辑。
包括有用的逻辑
包括他商业化的逻辑。
包括他怎么赚钱
他怎么做到今天的逻辑。
大家有兴趣的话
可以去参谋环安
听听我跟苏清洋老师交流的。
有几期
包括潘朗老师在乱翻书里。
也聊过好多期关于小红书的。
其实听听这几期
大概也就理解的
可能会更透一点
他们都是作为社区专家。
去讲的
那最后最新的消息就是。
26年小红书
已经在请高盛和中金。
为潜在香港的IPO工作了。
目前二级市场估值。
根据路透社的报道。
大概在500亿美元。
上市之后
大家普遍认为会超过700亿美元。
这也就是最新的消息了。
看看年底之前
会不会有进一步的动作。
最后简单再说一说小红书的话。
可能有什么几个点可以聊。
第一点就是
小红书的确
现在是相当多人的搜索引擎。
2026年路透社。
把它称为中国年轻人的。
Defecto Search Engine。
就是事实意义上的搜索引擎了。
它已经替代搜索引擎了。
因为这里面有大量真实的生活。
经验数据库
社区变成了生产这些内容的机制。
而搜索是调取这些数据的入口。
为什么变成这样的机制呢？
是因为现在
大家首先不会在Pc网站上发消息了。
因为移动互联网时代到了。
顺手一发
你哪个地方堵车了。
拍一下 发一下
哪个地方有好玩的东西。
流量不一定大
但是它可以以门槛基地的方式发出来。
并且以门槛基地的方式被搜索到。
并且以门槛基地的方式获取一个赞。
确实经历过
你比如说前段时间去浦东。
坐那个大巴
到底应该怎么做
大家生活当中碰到类似的一些场景。
你可能习惯性的就是去。
所有一个笔记
会明确的告诉你
然后顺手我就点了一个赞。
本来也是收藏作用。
然后人家还专门回来。
谢谢你给我的赞
对于双方来讲
都是一个良性的回应。
一个闭环了
我自己个人很喜欢小红书。
也是感觉小红书有早期互联网的一些精神。
就是个人创作者的分享。
这点很重要
因为现在我们看到了很多内容平台。
当然也是创作者分享。
但是很多都是PGC。
甚至是更大的工作室。
公司在运营的
所谓个人互联网
其实在前些年是一度消失的。
UGC的内容就越来越少。
当然你可以说
现在小红书也有很多创作者。
也有很多PGC的内容。
营销内容
也有很多跟微博类似的地方。
但是大家肯定也会有感受。
像刚才肖蕾说的那种。
你在一个地方转机。
或者说在一个地方。
搜一些小众的内容。
它真的只有小红书上能找得到。
因为有一些
真的是活生生的个人。
自己分享的一些小经验。
这种东西比较多
大家总要有这个分享的出口。
找哪呢？
小红书
第二就是小红书
也是公众化的朋友圈。
因为其实微信由于它的膨胀。
你这里面不光是你早先的朋友。
你后来的同事
各种关系都在上面了。
大家发朋友圈的意愿就别少了。
发帖越来越有压力。
在小红书上
就开始用自己的小红书账号发。
而且小红书账号容易找到同号。
这个大家应该
可能也会有感受
你在朋友圈里发吧？
你有的时候你还得。
标一下这个组别
有的时候你发一个东西。
你开了个玩笑
但是长辈可能不喜欢你开这个玩笑。
或者说领导不喜欢你开这个玩笑。
或者说你还能冒犯其他的一些人。
你就好烦啊？
无所谓
我小红书上发就无所谓了。
因为我可能会冒犯的这些人。
一定概率 大概率吧？
可能不会刷得到
主要还是找着同号嘛？
所以它这慢慢的
大家就会更愿意
在小红书上发这个朋友圈。
这是一个点
第三是
从互联网社区历史来看。
小红书其实你会发现。
我们之前讲的贴吧论坛。
小红书用推荐算法。
重新发明了贴吧和论坛。
之前小红书
已经正式改过品牌口号了。
我们前面说它是购物攻略。
购物攻略
后来小红书做大之后。
长期有一个slogan。
叫做你的生活指南。
有印象
后来用了十几年的口号。
现在已经改掉了
叫做你的生活兴趣社区。
它就有点不太一样。
不光有
但是是这个事
就是前几年
它慢慢的就是从最早的有用。
网这个
你有兴趣
大家可以在这交流。
当然还是有用
但是我们是一个
你可以交流小众的。
黑胶
我就喜欢养个西瓜虫。
对吧？
大家西瓜虫的人
你在别的地方
不可能有个西瓜虫论它。
给我的感受
从引导上来说
从最开始让你在这找内容。
变成了希望你在这留下内容。
对交流大家一起
第四就是小红书
因为刚才说的这些动作。
因为它覆盖的越来越多。
它泛化了
它不是说之前大家想象的。
女性购物
什么精致
精品社区
现在已经变成了
容纳各种兴趣爱好的社区。
所以它会吞掉大量的垂直社区。
比如说马蜂窝
下厨房好好住
甚至包括大众点评。
和知乎的一部分内容。
一部分需求都被提搭掉了。
这个跟我们刚才说的。
兴趣爱好
不同场景的内容
可以聚合和分发是有关系的。
从这四点来看
虽然形式上
看起来有点像海外的Instagram。
但是内容
上面已经差别非常大了。
你稍微用大一点的词说。
已经可以构成了
普通中国人的生活信息的。
基础设施了
最后我看到财新的报道里面。
引用了一位小红书的。
战略投资方人士的评价。
他是这么说的
他说小红书乱七八糟。
但是生机薄薄
这个评论还挺有意思的。
因为乱七八糟
大家就会下意识的想。
因为不聚焦
你早晚要做黄
存在这个可能性
做什么都不惊
但是加上生机薄薄。
也特别符合大家的感受。
你会觉得好像是这么个事。
好像它就是护卫因果的。
你就是因为乱七八糟。
才能生机薄薄
就是因为生机薄薄。
所以显得乱七八糟。
当然了你看
包括刘飞一路讲过来。
大家经历过很多时代。
不同的时代
不同的主平台也不一样。
可能再往前推个多少年。
大家干这些事
更多的是在微博上。
去分享了一次的内容。
再往前
虽然天涯剥挪不了这么多。
但是一些垂直类的。
其他的平台
都能分别承担这个任务。
比如说你再过10年。
小红书后时代
肯定他还要会
被其他的不知道什么平台替代。
也可能是自己隔自己的命。
也可能是被别人革命。
这个就要走着看了。
对 就像前面说的小红书。
还是在移动互联网时代。
如果这个产品形态。
没有太大的变化的话。
它确实找到了一个比。
PC时代的那些论坛和BBS。
更合理
大家刷起来
更满足需求的一个形式了。
说完小红书
我们来到第二回
讲讲另一个公司
话说
我们得把镜头来到日本。
90年代末
日本有一个公司
叫Divango。
这个Divango。
做的是什么呢？
连网对战平台
有点像号方对战平台。
然后一直创业创业。
做到后面
他们觉得不行
咱也得跟上互联网时代。
到了2006年
他们决定做一个
类YouTube的视频网站。
加入轰轰类类的创业。
他们的这个视频网站。
定名叫做NicoNico。
NicoNico。
就是直接对比较YouTube的。
但是后来因为竞争太激烈了。
他们说
我们还是做个垂类吧？
咱们做啥垂类呢？
在本土
咱们就做个本土化的垂类。
动漫吧？
日本动漫更发达
所以NicoNico。
刚开始做这个
他们最大设计出来一个。
改变世界互联网产品历史的。
一个非常重要的功能。
就是播放动画的时候。
在时间轴上
可以放出在这一刻。
用户的评价
评论区跟其他的一样。
但是我评论区是带时间戳的。
有个打标的什么机制了。
也就是我们今天说的弹幕了。
早期他们甚至
自己都没有视频托管。
什么意思呢？
就是你看的是YouTube。
就是那个欠的YouTube。
这里面的弹幕是我的。
内容是YouTube的。
它只有框
早期的很多视频网站都是这样的。
现在是不让爬外恋了。
早期的视频网站
你都可以随便欠到任何地方的。
这是一个历史时期的事情。
所以为什么是历史。
就07年YouTube就封掉了。
所有外恋的欠入是访问。
所以NicoNico自己被迫。
做了自己的托管
而就在他上线一年之后。
日本流量就已经超过了YouTube。
到今天都是日本
非常重要的一个视频网站。
在日本的流量
而且不光是动漫的内容。
当年他们
日本也有政治辩论。
政治家的辩论
当年安倍晋三就在NicoNico上。
直播过他跟精神对手的辩论。
当时辩论的时候
甚至后面有个巨大的。
显示屏
显示屏上飘弹幕
两个人边辩论
边有弹幕飘弹
很有意思
很先进 很新潮
很壮观
后来还有人把中国的春晚。
搬到了NicoNico上。
这个在NicoNico也非常火。
很多人都表示很震撼。
这个真的是
没看过这种类型的。
都是大场面
那么NicoNico。
既然是一个动漫网站。
所以当时不光是在日本了。
在中国的动漫爱好者的群体里面。
也很有影响力
所以在2007年。
有一个平时用酷溜的创作者。
他叫做西林
想做一个类似NicoNico的网站。
他觉得这个有机会。
大家一块抽一块
做这么一个网站
他本来就是一个创作者。
一个创作者
6月6号他的网站上线了。
叫做AC Fan。
A是animate动画。
C就是comic漫画。
动漫吧 AC
2008年AC Fan网站引入了弹幕。
而AC Fan在之之后。
是一炮而红
当时中国的二次元爱好者。
动漫爱好者也非常多。
大量的创作者也开始在这个平台上。
进行二创
A站迅速扩大
这就是大家常说的。
常说的A站
很多今天耳熟能相的梗。
其实最早是A站上出现的。
比如说金克拉
非洲农业步伐的
都要卖它
金克拉
有土地需要的弹林甲。
德国古科
什么元首的愤怒
这些很多二创的重要的这些梗。
在A站上其实都已经有了。
但是呢？
A站毕竟一开始
还是一个很年轻的创作者。
爱好者自己传的网站。
所以他的组织存在很大的问题。
他特别像我们的校园BBS。
就是很松散的管理机制。
大家网友们交流
这个网友
慢慢的就类似做版主。
管理员了
以后就参与一些经营。
但是他并没有像创业公司一样。
刚开始去定下谁有决策权。
或者定下股权的分配都没有。
站长就是从这里面选。
到了2009年
本来应该是A站最好的时候。
结果内部爆发了激烈的内部斗争。
这些管理者们
大家互相有了很多局域。
吵架了
挺起来很合理
不到最好的时候不需要斗争。
吵架之后的结论就是。
谁都不管了
我不管了
他说我也不管了
大家都不管了
无人大理
怎么办呢？
而创始人西林在这个时候。
又做了一个非常让人兮兮的决定。
他决定直接把A站卖了。
你看我们之前
中国互联网故事讲了这么多故事。
好像一件事越做越大。
是天经地义的
而且都能越做越大。
但其实不是
历史上很多这种公司。
很多创业者
在真实的历史上
创业未办而中道崩溯。
对 这就是滴滴撞撞的。
很多在支线上
各种十字路口
最后就选走了另外一条。
对于当时西林来说。
我卖挺好
他就卖给了
杭州编封武汉分公司总经理。
陈少杰当时的价格是400万。
那你说对于西林来说。
我一个爱好者
我最后做了网站400万。
回家养老了
海边做个房子
我就躺一辈子了
也可以
也能叫自由了
陈少杰拿到之后
就开始做很多新的努力。
包括比如关注游戏赛事。
因为动漫爱好者
动漫和游戏本来也不太分家。
在AC贩场做直播。
后来直播业务争争日上。
陈少杰在2014年。
把A站的直播业务单独独立。
给他起名叫斗鱼
斗鱼直播就是这么来的。
这又是另外一条支线了。
但是A站本体
他自己的内容社区。
还是一直在走下坡路。
2014年奥非娱乐入股A站。
这不是在潮汕那期还提过。
管理层做了一波换鞋。
奥非是之前肖蕾讲过的。
做玩具的
到了2015年
到了什么阶段
我们之前讲的
视频网站大战那个阶段。
大家都知道内容版权。
要提上日程了
A站作为一个创业公司。
他又没有那么多的资金。
资本去做这个
所以他就被游库起诉了。
被游库起诉之后
怎么办呢？
拿了游库的钱
游库宣布以5000万美元入股A站。
然后如果A站之后。
游库又带头把管理层洗了一遍。
到这儿已经洗了三波了。
2016年这是一年一遍。
软银中国以6000万美元投资A站。
管理层再洗一遍
第四遍了
2016年同年中文在线。
再次投资A站
再洗一遍
你看看
就是你洗了这么多层。
已经换人换的妈都不认识了。
培修资支A站了
2017年AC范终于资金链断裂。
11月份网站一度。
无法访问
2018年A站北快手收购。
就在收购的同期
A站被黑客入侵
数据外泄
大量用户数据在暗网上出售。
这就显得说
你就知道他其实
已经没有能力
支撑他自己的网站的。
正常运营了
2018年初
A站曾经有一段时间。
一度无法访问
官方微博
只发了这么一句话。
我还想再活500年。
有点悲凉了
那么问题来了
现在A站还在吗？
还在
如果你输入acfan.com。
你还能打开
这视频当然比较旧了。
没什么太多新视频更新了。
但现在的日活
还在10万左右
还有全职的运营人员。
20人左右
但普通的
你看他新上传的视频播放量。
已经很难破万了
算是一个
中国内容社区的活化石了。
怀旧的地方了
就在A站说他
还想再活500年。
我真的还想再活500年的时候。
另一个跟他故事很相似的公司。
就要上市了
我们故事回到
就在A站非常动荡的2009年。
那个时候
A站服务器经常荡机。
前面也说了
管理层之前有矛盾。
经营不善
访问不稳定
网友们访问的时候就觉得很难受。
有一个A站的网友忍不了了。
既然官方不给力
我自己做
他花了三天
临时搭了一个站点。
叫做MikuFans。
MikuFans是什么呢？
就听起来像是Miku的粉丝站。
初音未来
Miku就是大名鼎鼎的。
初音未来粉丝站
MikuFans最早。
就很多网友把他当成A站的备胎。
这个网友名字叫什么呢？
他叫圈9B10
什么玩意
圈9
他是那个
Fuhaw
是那个圈里边是个9。
圈里边是个9
这个圈9
他又来源于东方project。
东方project是邓玉老师。
也很喜欢的那个作品。
我们之前提到过
里面的角色来自
齐路诺
这个鼻屎又是随便起的一个名字。
中文它会写成
B诗
雪碧的B
诗文的诗
B诗
这个圈9B10
它是一个浙江人
真名叫做徐义
徐义
高中的时候就非常喜欢动漫。
后来在北京幼殿大学读书。
在读书期间
就开始传MikuFans了。
MikuFans。
后来觉得
咱不行
咱不能支持Miku的Fans。
咱还是
做一个乍巴景的改个名吧？
后面改名叫做BiliBili。
这名字是这么来的。
BiliBili是什么意思呢？
BiliBili是放电的女生词。
BiliBili。
这么一个BiliBili。
之前我们设计过
来自什么科学的超电磁炮。
某科学超电磁炮里面的。
预版美琴
来自这么一个角色。
它的技能叫BiliBiliBili。
由于A战实在是太不争气了。
很多网友口碑相传。
口口相传说
那儿有个B战
咱上B战看吧？
也有那个东西
半价
慢慢的都搬到B战了。
从一开始
大家觉得B战是A战的一个小分站。
后来大家觉得B战比A战还好用。
但早期看B战和A战。
差别确实也不是很大。
它也有点像一个社团而已。
大家自己传的
也很松散
很松散
早年B战没钱的时候。
香港的用户访问速度特别慢。
忍不了了
捐钱
给租服务器
它租香港当地的CDN服务器。
给你们用
提供给B战
包括成都美国也都有人直接捐钱。
给它免费的服务器给B战。
看看
自由生长出来的
B战最早App的Windows phone版本。
当时没人开发
是一个微软员工
用业余时间给它写的。
甚至徐毅
后来全职做
他在杭州创业要做这个B战。
他在杭州用的办公场所。
都是用户找自己爸妈。
以明显低于市场家的价格。
就是全靠大家帮忙。
这是一个
怎么说田园时期
互联网田园时期的一个很淳朴的。
很朴素的一种适团关系。
起家故事让人听得很舒爽。
就在徐毅做B战的时候。
2011年他收到了一封邮件。
内容是
我是陈锐
对你们这个网站很感兴趣。
我们能不能见一见。
来了
徐毅就赶快去小红书。
那个时候没有小红书。
徐毅赶快去百度搜了一下。
发现
这个人是金山网络副总裁。
大佬 企业家
人物
见见吧？
两个人就在2011年的春天。
世纪会面
就在杭州
就在我们在的杭州的某个地方。
某个房间里面见面了。
陈锐当时就问了他一句话。
Bilibili这个名字。
是因为某科学的超电磁炮里不好解。
他懂啊？
上来就知道
这个一般人都不懂的。
你得对二次元非常了解。
你得看了才知道
对 你不是说
现在大家一搜百多百科就有。
当时B站还是个很小圈子的网站。
所以他是真看过
他是真喜欢
那陈锐为什么要找徐毅。
他到底要找他干啥呢？
说来话长
我们也说说陈锐
在之前我们讲手机的那期。
讲雷军和小米的时候提到过陈锐。
陈锐1978年出生于成都。
他父母都是民航系统。
当时是在做三线建设时期的时候。
来到西南地区的
算是一个移民家庭。
陈锐基本上也是在。
厂区大院里出生的。
而那个时候他的大院里。
条件还不错
78年出生的
四岁的时候已经有电视机了。
在八九十年代
日本动画进入中国之后。
陈锐就是中国第一代。
看到聪明的一修啊？
机器猫啊？
再后来就是龙猪
生都是关了高手的小朋友。
陈锐高中在成都期中读书的。
我们之前提过一嘴。
王小川是他的同班同学。
甚至不光是同班同学。
还是他的同班同桌。
他俩同桌过呀？
什么奇妙的缘分
一方面呢？
成都期中确实很厉害。
一般上学校的学生都很聪明。
另外一方面
跟他们这代人也有关系。
互联网的红利
它也是有时代特征的。
我们讲鬼谷神话
讲中国互联网
大家都会有体会
陈锐后来采访的时候。
也自己说
说我人生的几个节点。
几乎都跟赶个开放。
同拍啊？
都赶上了时代的红利。
94年
陈锐家里已经有了电脑。
发景确实很不错
而且从此之后
陈锐因为特别喜欢电脑。
他在后来买的所有电脑。
都是自己组装的
从来不直接买品牌电脑。
说明当时也是一个发烧友。
作为发烧友
他也是跟我们讲过的。
这些故事都是一个剧本的。
很早就开始学习编程了。
2001年
陈锐从成都信息
工程大学毕业
基于兴趣
陈锐加入了金山软件。
2002年就成了。
雷军的技术助理
还成了雷军的干部培训班成员。
把它直接当干部培养。
2006年
培养成了
陈锐已经是金山独霸。
失业部的总经理
金山独霸的一号位了。
刚毕业五年了
而且是2006年的金山独霸。
但是他自己也做不住。
陈锐就回忆说
我当时就觉得
继续留在金山
死路一条
必须出去闹革命
还这么说的
一号位有这种觉悟。
那就说明一号位
也没有那么自疑
但是后来回忆说
这个想法还是有点幼稚了。
出去也没那么容易。
真不容易外边
也喝不凉天地宽
龙鸡有食汤过劲的。
真的是
2008年
陈锐也拉了个团队。
就做了贝克安全
这么一个公司
这个创业项目是做云安全的。
在当年是很重要的。
就很流行那个项目。
他们自己整服务器。
这个时候就发现这个难度了。
因为是突闭的业务。
整个过程就做得很艰苦。
他们自己整完服务器。
那个机房里面
甚至还要自己装机架。
扯网线
有一次陈锐
啪啪就掉进同棚道里了。
同棚道里
同棚道挺大呀？
大是大
主要是大是一方面。
轮轮的那个就太危险了。
但是里面确实有好多金属之价。
满条腿都是血
就是血肉模糊
他最后就跟大家讲说。
这个是极照
为什么呢？
因为过去
中国古代著名剑
都得弄点血
我现在搞服务器了。
我这低了血的服务器。
他就跑得快
不光自我安慰
还会稳定居心
2010年
被可安全
被金山并购了
陈锐成为金山网络。
他就不是之前的金山度霸了。
金山网络
也就是后来
列爆移动的联合创始人。
不管是之前在金山软件。
还是现在在金山网络。
都是直接跟雷军汇报的。
相当于跟副胜
是一个搭档关系
也就是在这一年
陈锐成了B站的日火用户。
每天差不多花半个小时看B站。
他是真喜欢
越看越喜欢
他自己就追翻
当时什么魔法少女小园。
Fate Zero。
刀剑神域
罪恶王冠等等
都会追
一方面是自己很有兴趣。
很有热爱
另外一方面
他又憋不住了
闹革面
他不想打工
这就说到这个邮件了。
他想先接触一下徐毅。
看看B站这边是什么情况。
见到徐毅之后
两个人的房间里
那天据说一直聊到凌晨三点钟。
很聊得来
当时
陈锐就问徐毅
你是想要卖一辈子。
糖水
到底是谁问谁
陈锐当时是这么问的。
他说你是想
就做一个爱好者的社团。
还是想正儿八经
做一家互联网公司。
徐毅说
我想做一家公司
陈锐说
你想做一家什么样的公司。
他说
要不你说吧？
也就是像盛大那么大的空。
当时的盛大
我一下给他勾出来了。
陈锐就说
搞得过
首先他先投资了B站。
以顾问的方式
参与公司组建
我来帮你
我来帮你做盛大
然后推动B站
做大做强
然后陈锐的加入
就让B站的故事
在这个十字入口这儿。
发生了一个巨大的变化。
本来就像A站这么一个社团。
一个小组织
做的一个爱好者的小项目。
但是现在
他越来越像一家商业公司了。
很快
在2014年
列爆移动上市了
陈锐对他来说
实际到了
跟雷军和附生
沟通过之后
退出列爆
全职加入B站
不光自己去
他还拉了列爆的同事李宁。
李宁
后来成为B站的副董事长。
和COO
李宁也非常厉害
他在26岁的时候。
加入列爆
就直接成为
整个列爆
人力资源的负责人了。
直接
他们三个人
是B站
可以说是三个真正的。
创始人
徐毅当然都说是创始人了。
但是陈锐和李宁的。
加入相当于
让B站完全脱胎换骨了。
所以这三个人
一般也被称为B站。
三见客
徐毅在2019年开始。
逐步淡出日常管理。
到今天
陈锐和李宁
一直算是双核心管理层。
说起来
现在李宁
接受媒体采访也比较多。
而且之前
他有一个非常知名的新闻。
就是
他丈夫是B站的UP主。
这在B站圈子里
也算是一个
很有意思的小区闻了。
通过工作关系
给自己找到了丈夫。
由工作延伸到了生活。
徐毅和陈锐
也算是互联网历史上的。
一个美堂了
因为徐毅自己的确。
他跟前面说的西林一样。
很早就产生过退出的想法。
他自己首先没有
经营公司的经验
他自己也没有
太多经营公司的兴趣。
刚开始就跟陈锐商量好了。
把一部分股权
无常的转让给了陈锐。
后来陈锐的股权
也是一直越来越高的。
当然徐毅的股权
应该是一直比李宁。
还是要高一些的
你说格局能显出来。
同时也能看到
对自己来说
绝对是正向的回报。
是
他们自己这几方的关系。
一直处理得非常好。
不像我们看到
有一些互联网创业公司。
还是会有很多
私扯的事情
口水这样的事情
2014年11月。
陈锐正式担任
B站董事长兼CEO。
陈锐后来被问过
一个特别好的问题。
就是A站 B站
都是弹幕二次元社区。
但是为什么？
B站最后做成了
是
究竟做对了什么？
陈锐回答了9个字。
合法化
正版化
商业化
这就说到下面的节点了。
陈锐还有一个经典名言。
也可以作为我们这两期。
系列的一个重要的注角。
他说你不懂社区会死。
你只懂社区也会死。
点光不能太聚焦
我们之前也讲过
很多类似的故事
社区本身
他想要从那时候
所谓高净值的用户身上。
赚到钱
天然的没有很好的。
形式和土径
大家都得找自己的。
商业模式
那你如果不是把它。
当成一个商业公司经营。
你只是做一个爱好者社区。
那很容易就黄掉了。
但是你如果不懂这个。
你就像自杰系
一直想要做社区
一直有个社区梦
但是做得也很痛苦。
特别懂商业的
商业模式特别顺畅的。
可能也不行
说回来
他提到了这9个字。
合法化 正版化 商业化。
合法化就是申请各种。
自治和正照
那个时候很多网站。
做的就不是那么正规。
也不会想太多
特别是这种爱好者。
本来就是自己搭的一个东西。
正版化就是不举版权。
和游戏发行
看动画早期
大家都是搬运的
直接搬
这个时候就要采购了。
其实在合法化和正版化方面。
死掉的社区
可太多太多了
因为刘肥之前也讲过。
视频网站的大战了。
那个时候花钱如流水。
那从刚开始买番的时候。
买番就是买新番
买东曼
陈睿就表示
B站自己购买的正版新番。
不加视频贴片广告。
这是在2014年。
他就说出了这句话。
这句话也后来被反复引用。
就不加贴片
这个从陈睿进入B站就确定了。
商业逻辑上
不是一个很高效的一件事情。
他跟字节戏是完全反面的。
我们之前讲过
抖音天才之处
就是他广告逻辑非常完美。
广告融入内容
你刷刷刷
就把广告看完了
转化率也非常高
跟印钞机一样
你如果不再最多曝光。
最直接的地方赚钱。
你就只能间接搞
后来B站搞的充电。
投币大会员
会员购
UP主商业合作等等。
其实摩擦力
都是比直接放广告。
要大的
这也是跟
所谓大家经常说
B站是中国的YouTube。
跟YouTube最大的。
一个差别的地方
关于贴片
我们后面还有专门的篇幅。
展开说一说
从陈睿的理解
这些新的商业化的路径。
是跟社区更加匹配和结合的。
因为你会发现
不管是充电
投币大会员这些
它都围绕人跟人的关系。
为什么是人跟人的关系。
因为社区是一个典型的特征。
就在于人跟人的关系。
B站的社区文化
有很多方面
一直在做社区的建设。
一直在关注人跟人的关系。
比如说他跟虎铺一样。
也需要会员答题
到2025年底
已经有2.84亿正式会员。
从过100道题的考试。
加入社区了
当然这个2.84亿里。
肯定很多也不一定是。
都是动漫爱好者
但是也得考这个事。
后来B站又有了一个。
针对动漫影视爱好者的。
硬核会员试炼
我之前尝试过好多次。
在不作弊的情况下。
是非常非常非常难的。
我到现在都没有通过。
知识密度非常高
找到都是什么技巧干啦的题。
想象不到的
2010年B站曾经征集。
占娘
最后两个作品
票数相同
都留下来了
一个就是22娘
一个是33娘
还有像拜年纪 百大UP主。
BML
BML就是线下演唱会等等。
这些
再加上各种各样的内部梗。
甚至你会发现
这些梗都不是
是整个社区的梗
它甚至是围绕
这个UP主
自己和观众之间
形成的很默契的内部梗。
这都是体现
B站文化的一些层面。
这些层面
B站是一直想办法。
看能不能
让他们有更多的
商业化的方向
可以探索的
因为毕竟没有
那个体验广告
说回来
2016年
因为版权方要求
B站在RE
从零开始的
一世界生活等五部作品。
放入商业贴片广告。
刚说了就来了
引起了巨大的反弹。
陈睿亲自道歉
提出承包过番剧的。
用户不看广告
以承包相关番剧的钱。
退回广告可以调过。
并且
就是在16年留下来。
那句更著名的话
B站未来有可能会倒闭。
但绝不会变质
你看看
这句话说了以后
贴片想家就更难了。
同年10月
B站退出大会员
陈睿表示
正版新翻
不加贴片广告的原则不变。
18年上市之前
已经表示
整个B站
不会有贴片了
所以说
陈睿在B站
刚成立那些年
提到的
不加贴片是有条件的。
但是到后来
慢慢犯话了
就是广义上的
都不加贴片了
2022年左右
B站内容上面
做了一个新的功能。
就是
数评Story Mode。
说是Story Mode。
其实就是短视频
2023年Story Mode。
已经占
全占播放量的30%了。
这个数字比我想象的。
还是高的
这对于商业化来说。
是更加乐观的
因为我们前面也说了。
抖音这种形式
它的广告商业化
是更多样的
2022年
B站也开始
向电商平台开放导流。
这个跟小红书一样。
接入了淘宝联盟
推出了新火计划
2023年上半年。
有3000万用户。
通过点击
B站的视频
曲链接进行交易
而B站进入
淘宝店铺的用户中。
70%都是新客
这个引流的效果非常好。
可能都是因为
是年轻的网友吧？
质量还是很高的
2026年4月8日。
B站通过
创作机利官方账号。
通知创作者
4月10日起
上线播放页暂停广告。
它是暂停广告
它不是贴片广告
但它也是广告
这是作为贴片广告的一种替代。
现在大家看的时候。
可能有的时候也会遇到。
我遇到过几次了
所以B站也不是说。
大家说的那种
坚持不做视频里的广告。
它只是不做
强制打断时的广告。
那么贴片不是
主要的商业化途径。
哪些是它主要的途径。
好什么赚钱
大家可能有印象
早期主要提到的就是游戏。
靠游戏赚钱
Fate Ground Order。
2016年9月上线的游戏。
Fate系列
首先它是一个
在二次元的整个社区。
整个人群里
非常有基础的
有群众基础的一个动画。
B站获得了FGO。
中国大陆的独家代理权。
这款游戏的
上线前30天
就吸引了450万的玩家。
FGO的畅销到什么程度。
在畅销网上的排名。
一度超过了王者荣耀。
这个很厉害
FGO就是刚说Fate Ground Order。
2015年B站的游戏收入。
只有一点316亿。
2016年直接篡到5.23亿。
你想想
它篡了多少
小四个亿
一倍不止
2017年做到了24.68亿。
在跨年做到了20多亿。
每年都是翻了
四五倍
小五倍了
这一年还上线了
另一个报款叫做必兰航线。
看着大家就会觉得。
B站终于找到了一个。
能赚钱了
能养活自己
甚至不光是能养活自己。
刚才说的小红书
跟大厂能一拼一样。
网易当年
不是也是做一个
好像上一代的小公司。
找到了一个
成为新时代的大公司的路径。
B站这就是小网易。
合作的小网易
2017年游戏收入。
在总收入的83.4%。
FGO和必兰航线。
分别贡献了公司走收入的。
71.8%和12.7%。
这组成也越看越像网易。
而且这个
会让大家觉得
比较乐观的地方在于。
它不会过度消耗社区氛围。
你社区和游戏
我是相对隔离的
这里面你如果放太多广告的话。
那贴八的教训
历历在目
所以大家也觉得
这个游戏很好
所以就在2018年3月28日。
B站也趁机登陆纳斯达克了。
当时大家就问
哎呀你这上市有点急吧？
你是不是觉得这个游戏。
就这么一拨了
陈瑞是这么说的
她说佛系创业者也能上市。
上市之后
我不看股价就行了。
我做这么快的原因就是。
我想快点做完
安心回去干活
这么说的
这个事咱们还要干。
反正给的理由是这样的。
上市之后
当然也首先遭遇了。
跟小红书一样的问题。
什么问题呢？
治理问题
2018年7月
国家网信办联合督部门集中整治。
短视频名台
B站 秒拍
五六视频等平台
被约谈
部分F被应用上电。
下架整改
B站随后宣布
全面整改
内容审核团队
扩编一倍以上
所以你看
这种审核等等这些层面。
也不是说前面说的一个小公司。
一个社团爱好者能做的。
干不了
接下来内容治理的要求就更高。
或者说公司化建议更正规了。
同年B站还保留了。
社区自治市治理的机制。
这个在内容平台里也很少见。
还有版主
不是 跟咸鱼一样。
咸鱼不是也有自治吗？
这里面B站的老用户。
可以申请成为风计委员。
也非常二次元
纪律委员
长江大妈要监督
带个袖标
你可以参与一些案例的判断。
遭到处罚的用户
会进入小孩屋
我给你关一阵子
不能出来了
这个监管体制
就又让用户
又让社区里面的
这些人能参与进去了。
接下来2018年10月。
腾讯向B站追加
三亿多美元的投资。
2019年2月
淘宝又买了B站
两千多万股
所以腾讯和阿里都入股。
B站了
腾讯和阿里都买的公司。
其实没有那么多
我们之前提过的
小红书也是
包括滴滴有那么几家。
2019年B站的很多动作。
越来越接近
常见的互联网公司了。
比如说它成立了增长部门。
开始做很多品牌投放。
综艺的冠名
渠道的拉星
19年年底
也是它第一次举办。
跨年晚会
B站的跨年晚会
在年轻群底非常受欢迎。
甚至被很多人认为。
是最好看的跨年晚会。
2019年这届的跨年晚会。
是史上评分最高的跨年晚会。
豆瓣评分到了9.0。
人民日报直接夸它。
是最懂年轻人的晚会。
这一年B站慢慢开始破圈了。
而破圈在2020年。
达到了顶峰
2020年五四青年节。
前夕合兵出演了
B站制作的短片
《后浪》这个三不曲。
还有《入海》和《喜相逢》
起码《后浪》和《入海》
是引起了两波大的讨论热潮的。
巨大的争议
有一些年轻人觉得。
这个《后浪》代表不了。
真正的年轻人
有的人就认为
你这个太窄了
你这个描述的是
城市中产年轻人的消费生活。
这是消费主义的东西。
当然也有很多人很喜欢。
觉得它代表了年轻人的精神。
不管争议怎么样
这个事从B站的战略角度。
是非常成功的
是远超预期的
因为它很重要的一点。
不是让大家觉得
这个短片本身好不好。
而是让大家意识到。
B站它不是说是一个。
二次元社区了
还狭窄的东西
它是一个年轻人社区。
不光是《后浪》这几部短片。
在这前后几年
B站其实长期做很多自治内容。
这些自治内容跟动漫。
也没什么太大关系了。
比如说他做了纪录片。
《人生一串》
他当时很出名
《守护解放西》等等。
是一种保守好评的节目。
在各方因缘计会的情况下。
也出现了大量的知识领域的创作者。
何同学 碧岛 半佛等等。
他们也很有代表性。
而其中最最破权
也被B站认为是一个。
非常核心的标志
就是中国政法大学的罗翔老师。
大家知道B站能看罗翔了。
而且罗翔是一个
B站有代表的创作者。
那就天然意味着
他跟二次元毫无关系。
他跟鬼畜毫无关系。
大家就知道B站
好像现在不光是那些东西了。
现在大家意识到
B站上面有知识 财经 科技 汽车。
美食 法律 医学 历史。
健身 装修 母婴 生活记录。
什么东西都有了
这个时候他就真的。
进入到破圈的时代了。
2020年底
B站的MAO
就是它的月活是2亿。
日活是5000多万。
2021年底
一年之后
它的月活是2.7亿。
日活穿到了7000多万。
它的日活增长会更凶猛。
2020年全年收入是120亿。
2021年达到了194亿。
增长62%
用户数据和商业数据。
双双信高
疫情期间
这个故事就变成了B站用户。
当时官方的许识和大家讨论。
也经常会认为
当年看东曼这些年轻人长大了。
长到了上班了
上班了什么数码 汽车。
它就更有商业价值了。
从数据上看
的确也是一直增长的。
2018年
官方发布的B站的平均。
用户年龄是21岁。
26年已经是26.5岁了。
确实在增长
但这个过程当中也是。
洗油参半
这段时期
你只要在内容平台领域。
有了流量
字节就得盯上了
西瓜视频开始积极硬战。
成立大臂办
2020年春节花了6个亿。
拿下了9妈
线上的播应权
这个大家有点印象。
争议还是很大的
那年也是套田俱浪。
后来也不断的挖UP主。
最早挖的熬餐长
后来最知名的那个。
巫师财经
巫师财经就独家
在西瓜视频开始发了。
这种故事
我们之前也当然也讲过很多。
他用这种策略和这种路径去做。
其实是很难形成社区氛围的。
所以在2021年底。
西瓜视频宣布并入抖音。
开始收缩了
这算是B站当时
遇到的一个小波浪。
2021年
各方面数据到了新高峰。
像刚才小蕾说的
也在疫情期间再上市。
这次是二次上市
2021年3月
B站在香港二次上市。
说起来挺有意思的。
他这两次上市
当然做一个创作者社区。
他肯定都要请创作者。
他这两次请的创作者。
跟大家念一念
大家也会有感受
还挺有意思的
他找了一些代表
上次第一次上市
悄中的阿普主
参与的有Lex
咬人猫
墨运
渗透之C军
高有斯
细似炸弹
吃素的狮子
查理理理子
高有斯他后来
外国人研究中心
更多的是通过这个人。
认识他的
像Lex之前
也有很多争议的新闻。
可能不看他
也知道他出过一些事。
制作的狮子
我之前刷的比较多。
后来刷的也比较少了。
这些大部分是生活类博主。
生头之C军是游戏博主。
我看那个C军
之前看他的
恐怖游戏解说比较多。
而二一年这次上市。
邀请的阿普主是
熬场长
保健嫂
必导
范氏
机制的党妹
老番茄
合同学
良风
绵羊料理
伊丽莎白鼠
半佛
和Zetrack。
是这么几位
可能大家知道的
会稍微多一些
是的
但是之后
B站高举高打
也开始不断的
买版权
扶持阿普主
支持国曼
做电竞
做游戏
那个时候能看得到他。
那手里
现金流确实充裕了。
摊子铺得非常大
但是
很多业务做的
没有特别大预期
之前B站
是想在2023年。
做到4亿的MEO的。
最后没有做到
月活做到了3.36亿。
而且2022年
收入增长
就只有13%了
你就会发现
这个增长的时期
就结束了
破圈
是不是就差不多
迫到这个程度了
也就是在2023年。
B站再次宣布
调整战略
从之前
宣布的铺摊子
高速增长
开始减速
财报会里
开始提
profitability。
盈利能力
或者你叫利益
润水平也可以
就感知到了
他这个月活
和他面向的
消费群体
在中国人口构成里。
差不多也就到顶了。
本来你的潜在用户。
基本上也就洗过一遍了。
那接下来怎么办呢？
就不是拉薪了
就要做好留存
和商业价值
还是前面
同样所有社区
都要面临的课题
怎么能让用户
更多参与到
商业活动里来
咱都给点钱
投钱
视频的核心指标
从之前的播放次数。
改成了播放时长
不是只鼓励大家
做标题党
提升打开率了
但是这是
比较正面的说法
当然前面说的
这个所谓收缩
所谓讲究
将本增销
做好留存等等
这是正面的说法
负面的说法
就是开始裁员了
开始业务收缩了
之前扯着蛋了
2022年11月。
B站内部邮件宣布。
游戏发行事业部
游戏合作部
游戏社区部
和多个自研工作室。
所有游戏
本来分拆的几个部门。
全部并到一块
改为直接向陈睿汇报。
为啥呢？
就是因为之前
摊子铺得太大了
有钱以后
稍微没收住了
陈睿得自己盯一盯。
有一个明确的数据。
你看前面
铺了这么多摊子
它应该是有6个
游戏自研的工作室的。
2022年游戏收入里面。
自研游戏的占比
你猜有多少
看来是不高呀？
20%以下
只有5%
花了最多精力
投入了最多人力的。
自研方面
效果不理想
非常不理想
2024年
增肥减瘦
战略收缩之后
效果确实显著
游戏重新增长40%。
做到了56亿元
主要的报款是
三国谋定天下
这个在三国系的
现在的手游里
还是挺知名的
有印象
虽然我自己不玩手游。
但是大概之前也了解过。
三国IP的手游里面。
这款口碑是非常好的。
2024年
B站的收入
又来到了268亿。
同比增长19%
毛利率从24年看。
已经提高到32.7%了。
24年全年亏损调整后。
只有3000多万了。
在这个几百亿的收入里面。
约等于平衡了
2025年全年盈利。
正好我们看看
2025年的这个财报情况。
全年盈利里面怎么占比呢？
增值服务
119亿
广告100亿
游戏64亿
IP延伸计其他19.7亿。
从现在看游戏
已经跟之前80%都。
完全变了天了
一般不到了
已经不是大头了
这显然不是坏事
大家都会评论
觉得说B站现在
更稳一点
这不是值和广告
还是能个分天下
你不是只靠广告
不是只靠游戏
这相对健康一些
另外就是
B站的游戏方面
还一直在继续造写。
2025年底
自言地逃离亚克夫。
也非常火爆
大家讨论了很多
这就关于B站
关于瑞总
大家都叫他叔叔
关于叔叔
也是挺不容易的叔叔。
首先他不是创始人。
他是爱好者加
职业经理人的身份。
但是能维持社区氛围。
造作版权
谈融资发行游戏
组织建设
进入资本市场
推动商业化上市等等。
这些东西
是非常难得的
他能一直在坚持
社区氛围的情况下。
把这些做成
那你对比过去的社区。
听完这两期
你当然可以说
他有很多东西
做的不如字节
有很多东西做的不如豆瓣。
但是你真说
能穿越周期的社区太少了。
猫铺 天涯 A站等等。
都没有特别能做起来。
但是说到这儿
猫铺天涯
上期上次讲社区
就很多朋友就问
怎么不讲猫铺
不讲天涯
我们在比较早之前讲过。
大家可以回去翻一翻。
是 正片是讲过的。
陈睿自己也说过
A站不具备
做一家互联网公司的能力。
而且从结果看
B站到现在
跟小公司一样
他不容易的地方就在于。
他还能维持
一定的失去氛围
你想想
现在是一个社交媒体。
一个内容平台
洪水猛兽的时代
还能不断的造梗
还能产生亚文化的地方。
已经很不容易了
B站还一直维持着。
做社区公司
做内容公司的一个风格。
我之前去B站公司的办公室。
感觉的确跟很多互联网公司。
不太一样
大家桌上
可以说非常热闹
每个人桌上都摆着好多东西。
各式各样自己喜欢的东西。
还是有点校园的感觉。
不是那么严肃
在这工作
很多人是挺开心的。
有人想上一期说的。
多半的办公室
争议
当然也一直有了
像前面提到了
很多UP主
很多创作者说
不赚钱了
现在不行了
包括有很多老用户觉得说。
他抛弃了这次员
现在的氛围在变差等等。
当然我还是会觉得。
这是规模特别大
带来的一些
难以避免的副作用。
今天你真要说
看一些深度的内容。
除了文章和书
播客
能想到的
很多好的内容
也就是在B站能找得到。
你可以说
它就是中文互联网的。
民间知识库和数字当安馆。
我看到有一个说法。
是说叫文化硬盘
你还真的挺贴切的。
很多历史资料
真的是在别的地方都没了。
B站还有
像我之前做饮料故事的时候。
有一些视听资料
你在别的网站都没了。
当年那些老广告什么的。
你要搜B站上能搜到很多。
很多小众资料
有很多人的分析的内容。
分析一个早期的产品。
分析一篇小说等等这些内容。
B站上有很多
所以还是希望小破站。
一直经营下去
就跟陈锐前面说的。
B站未来有可能会倒闭。
但绝不会变质
就希望是这样
那在这一回的最后。
我们前面提到了
有一个很有意思的话题。
我们还一直没展开。
就是贴片
贴片这个问题
看似是一个小问题。
但是实际上
它是B站商业化的一个。
很重要的选择
甚至它不是B站的选择。
它其实把贴片聊透。
你就能理解社区
理解社区的商业化。
甚至你可以理解互联网产品。
互联网增长的一些。
核心的问题
这个问题的讨论
各方观点都非常复杂。
所以我就突发气象。
把老手艺
童子功用一用
大学时期
当时打过辩论的
咱组织一个辩论赛。
然后自己分市两边。
跟大家辩论一下这个问题。
好 我们辩论赛开始。
首先反方先出场
反方就是说
反对睿总的
认为做贴片合理的这些人。
很多投资人
一些广告从业者
和一部发布主
是反方这一方的
反方一辩登场
谢谢主席
谢谢对方辩
这仪式敢拉满
谢谢小蕾
我是反方一辩
我先说一句
可能会让在座B站用户。
不太舒服的话
这份坚持
它是有代价的
B站从2018年上市。
到24年累计亏损。
200多亿
朋友们
这不是理念
这是账单
钱它不是平白无故没有的。
有人为它买了单
这个单该不该买
它是个问题
反正没花咱的钱
用户愿不愿意看广告。
这件事其实早就问过了。
问过了
2014年B站做过调研。
36%的用户
可以接受15秒广告。
35%的用户
可以接受30秒广告。
12%的用户
可以接受75秒广告。
你说的有道理
我是反方
就应该放广告
同意你
都问过了
说的好
对方便有
你要注意这个数字。
12%的人愿意等75秒。
什么概念
今天这个局面
买单的人
你当然可以说是投资者。
那也是阿卜主
阿卜主没钱赚
阿卜主过得多酷的日子。
你看
苦瓜子做那么多行内容。
为了保护用户体验。
阿卜主得饿着吗？
凭什么饿着
这件事本来是可以做标准化的。
你凭它做了标准化。
库存明确CPM定价透明。
广告主闭着眼睛就能买。
编辑成本几乎为零。
没有摩擦力
这不就是明摆着
所有平台都实现的商业模式。
你为什么不用
调研也调研了
商业模式也有
为什么不用
结果不做
不做
最后
结果是什么？
有解决问题吗？
广告就消失了
没有
广告没有消失
现在倒逼着创作者。
自己塞广告
那不也是塞吗？
而且还很麻烦
现在阿卜主得自己对接。
自己折腾
来悔改
效率低到不可思议。
这就不是合理的商业模式。
你就说
没有铁片
转转是什么？
神奇小路是什么？
妙界是什么？
那不就是往里硬塞吗？
硬塞了
这不跟铁片一模一样吗？
你塞的其实是麻烦。
简直是狼狈
所以我放立场非常清楚。
不做铁片不等于没有广告。
它只是把原本一次。
体面又有价值的广告。
变成了一百次狼狈。
又不体面的广告
谢谢
坑枪有力说得好
作梦这个逻辑
正方意变登场了
对这就支持睿总的。
谢谢主席
谢谢对方便有
谢谢肖磊
谢谢对方一遍
我是正方一遍
对方便有刚才那段话。
我几乎全部同意
全都不同意
全都同意
除了结论
前面说的都是为我方说话的。
这就是打辩论的
我想先问问一个问题。
B站卖的到底是什么？
对方从头到尾算的是什么账。
多少人
多少用户市场
什么库存CPM
这一套账它是合理。
它在抖音合理
抖音做的是什么生意。
它卖的是注意力
B站卖的是什么？
B站卖的不是注意力。
B站卖的是信任
大家对UP主是有信任的。
所以UP主自己筛。
恰恰是更好的一种方式。
哎呦腾
首先你没法筛
哎呦腾这种市民网站。
你只能贴票
所以他不得不选择贴票。
因为聚集你没法改。
没有UP主
UP主跟播客主播一样。
它可以更好的融入内容。
柔心供应链
而且UP主我可以选择。
我不喜欢神奇小路。
我就不要神奇小路。
UP主自己做一个背书。
自己做一个选择
这不是更好的事吗？
它有利于社区氛围。
UP主恰饭代表的是信任感。
广告主买的不止是这十几秒钟。
它买的是UP主愿意支持这个产品。
而且
请注意
一个技术性的差别。
刚才对方便有说的不对。
怎么不对
贴票不能直接跳过。
但是这塞进去的内容。
可以跳过
你想跳
你直接拖进去跳
能跳了
是给你自由了
而且
你从弹幕里找时间点跳就行了。
现在弹幕里都有
可以空降在三分二十秒。
明确告诉你了
对方便有
你觉得这个弹幕是抱怨吗？
不是抱怨
那是观众们
主主一起形成的恰饭默契。
你看看
想看的看
不想看的直接跳过。
这不必贴片好吗？
该让它挣的钱
它也挣了
也没耽误我
该跳的时候跳不耽误时间。
还有一层
对方便有
你可能忽视了
也是更根本的一层。
怎么说
大气层
我在大气层
我给你们说
贴片是什么概念
你自己琢磨一下
它有一个微妙的区别。
贴片对于用户来说。
它感觉是平台在跟你收税。
对不对
大家会觉得这是平台再给你的。
我凭什么要吃你这个。
但恰饭是我帮助
喜欢的阿普主恰饭。
阿普主借给我时间。
我可以接受
我给我喜欢的阿普主。
做了贡献了
我就想看转转
怎么着
我就看这个
我不想跟你平台看转转。
我想给这个阿普主看转转。
我跟平台没感情
跟这个阿普主有
同样是30秒
我为什么说结论反了。
你说到底哪个体面。
哪个不体面
我反而觉得
现在正是更体面的一种方式。
谢谢
说得好
我同意你
你说得非常对
反方二变登场了
胡说八道
对方秒
反方二变空这些情绪。
谢谢小蕾
对方
以为自己在大气层很了不起。
你在天上
但咱们还得落回地上聊。
得接地去
地上现在发生着什么事呢？
什么说
你说有广告
有广告
有收入
谁有收入
只有一小撮有收入。
不足也得分不同的人。
中腰部根本没有伤单。
腰疼
伤单是强顺周期的。
2022年B站广告收入增幅。
从上一年的145%。
直接掉到13%
十分之一都不刀
看不动了
注意
这不是慢慢掉的
这是一脚踩空
这就是从你大气层掉到地上了。
还砸出个坑来
很多阿卜主崩溃了。
伤单大幅减少
这些阿卜主
之前就是听了你平台的劝。
已经见了团队成本很高。
怨声在刀
摔得生疼
你给人家忽悠见气的。
紧接着
23年不就出现了大量的阿卜主停更风波吗？
很多百万粉丝的阿卜主公开暂停更新。
引起了很多热议
原因就是撞不到钱。
你不能让阿卜主们为爱发电。
百万粉丝
你在任何一个平台。
本来应该是完全能自己自足的一个平台。
你给补贴
给流量补贴就行
但是逼着
很多还是在为爱发电。
活不下去了
百万粉都活不下去。
都停更了
这还了得
而且上单
它不光是头中尾部不一样。
分部不均
它分区
影视解说
传统文化
个人纪录片这些区。
本来就很难接到上单。
不容易
你平台只有一种模式。
转转不头怎么办
它是偏称的
这个不均匀
对方边有说
信任可以变现
你这就是允许少部分人先变了线。
剩下一部分人永远不变线。
你在什么大气层
根据财星
在二三年的一次详细报道。
从行情看
分部太不均匀了
头部UP主一条可以拿多少钱。
一百万
但是
十万粉的UP主
你看起来还不错
十万粉
肯定能接到上单
能拿到三万
已经非常非常非常好了。
行情不好的时候
有十万粉的UP主。
两千块钱也接
你想想
我都做到十万粉了。
我最后连为爱发电。
我当业余爱好
我都快撑不起了
打飞药饭的呢？
当年有一个代理商就说过。
如果一个品牌
有一亿全案营销预算。
B站这个平台
可能能分到一千万。
但这一千万
基本上都集中在
超级头部UP主身上。
可能就几百万
几个UP主就分光了。
哪有中伟部的这个事啊？
品牌要基本上这个认知。
还是头在头部上
整体的效果更好
所以对方讲的这个信任。
我完全承认他存在。
我只想提醒一句
信任在B站
不是均匀分部的
他是应者通知的
谢谢
确实也得考虑平台生态。
只有那几个头部的平台活不下去。
你说得对
我同意你
又同意了
正方二边
登台了
NNN
对正方二边是个外国人。
说来说去
你这说23年啊？
你拿着23年的旧传票。
你登不上26年的这条新船呢？
你拿钱朝子剑
要斩本朝的棍
你看看这个腰尾部。
不也在接转转广告吗？
代理现在以前是
就是摩擦力的问题。
刚才小蕾说
为什么是这个现状。
当时代理他没有能力。
对接这么多的创作者。
现在对接上了呀？
今时不同往日了
而且反过来讲
你要是真上贴片
你就是把B站
往流量平台上推
往火坑里跳
库存一标准化
广告他就跟内容完全脱钩了。
你现在转转广告有很多。
拿不住
融合得很有意思
大家甚至还愿意
看下去跟大家玩个耿。
你到时候一贴
那可就乱套了
广告主不关心是谁在说话。
他只关心播了多少次。
你想象一下
到时候他这个数据指标。
汇往哪个方向去引导。
那B站跟别的内容平台。
还有什么区别
他就不是社区了
我们再说说爱犹腾。
你打开爱奇艺的时候。
你是有明确的目标的。
你脑子里想的是
我就看这个剧
我就看这个综艺
所以偏头75秒
你可以忍
因为你知道你后面有明确的45分钟。
等着你
这是确定性
相当于是你为了吃一顿好的。
你在门口排队
有道理
没问题吧？
B站的用户不是这样。
很多人是连续点
很多UP主的视频。
刷出来的
你是刷呀？
你刷完这个5分钟。
你可能再刷下一个10分钟。
再刷下一个5分钟。
如果说每一次打开。
都先看一次广告
B站的浏览方式
会发生根本性的变化。
社区产品
尤其害怕这个打断感。
琢磨一下
这个差别很微妙
而且每一个长度
也跟那个视频平台不太一样。
你看剧看综艺
那是目的地旅游
你去那个目的地的过程。
繁琐一点
你也就认了
可以理解
B站是City Walk。
你走这路边
到处都是牛皮显
你什么心情
我换个城市了
我们今天看爱游腾忙。
很少是刷的吧？
谁刷
你刷吗？
这不刷呀？
但是B站呢？
你想想一下
搜索和刷
是不是都非常多
那如果老打断
它就不一样了
你去逛景点
门口收个门票
天经地义
但是你进了景点
走两步
拐个弯有人给你要5块钱。
你是可以说时间短。
我每次贴个10秒行不行。
你当然不会觉得贵。
但是你会觉得烦
你说景区一次性
说玩着迪士尼不就完了吗？
是不是这个道理
咱也有数据
你老说数据
2026年第一季度。
B站日军使用时间。
达到119分钟
120分钟
这个跟爱游腾忙差不多。
你说你要是三牛皮鞋。
能到这么高吗？
同样是两个小时
这是刷出来了两个小时。
韩金亮不是一回事。
他内容跳得多
这个数字已经很惊人了。
谢谢
反方三面生产了
对方便有前虑即穷了。
开始胡说八道了
119分钟说明什么？
说明什么？
你又不是做实验做的。
我还空口我也可以说。
加了贴片变成500分钟。
对你硬性归因
你不可证伪
你没有双忙测试
这是个典型的逻辑。
自说自话
但我不跟你在逻辑上纠缠。
你这个什么社区
加视频就不能贴片。
你这个推论有一个巨大的反例。
有个名荒谎的反例。
YouTube
YouTube是UGC吧？
YouTube很多人也是看好多视频。
创作者也掐饭
他就很成功
前贴
后贴
中贴
走五分钟扣5块钱。
他这广告体系分成给创作者55%。
一年的广告收入300多亿美元。
用户跑了吗？
你看人家多健康
创作者跑了吗？
所以对方便有这套。
一贴片社区就死的因果关系。
那就是胡扯
有实际的反例
这更有逻辑的一个证明。
举出例子来了
好
你想想一个平台
作用34億MU
每天上亿的日活
每人每天
一两个小时的视频消费。
主动放弃全互联网历史上。
国金中外最成熟的广告位。
你这在商业上
它就不合理
这不叫克制
这叫浪费
谢谢
虽然话说的简短
但是非常切中肯清。
现在又支持反方了。
最后
正方三变
到解变了
我是正方三变
对方说到商业
他就有意思了
YouTube有一个B站没有的出口。
叫做Premium会员。
对方边有想清楚这个事的逻辑。
YouTube贴片广告。
它不只是广告
在YouTube。
你如果被广告烦到了。
你就可以买Premium会员。
去去广告
对不对
B站的大会员逻辑不一样。
它是买番具和权益的。
是
你是可以加去广告。
但是你要想想
为什么中国它不一样。
因为中国的互联网环境。
它就不一样
哪不一样
中国有only fans吗？
中国有substack吗？
国外的付费市场
到今天都很繁荣
大家都甚至花钱去买博客。
今天小宇宙上收个费。
你都会被骂
是不是
说得好
海外的耐飞
Apple TV。
这都很贵的东西
省台和付费认知不一样。
省台不一样
中国用户已经被
免费内容平台养雕了。
你如果说
你真的是做一个思想实验。
你想象一下
B站刷视频的时候。
广告变多
大家会怎么样
你替代品太多了
抖音精选
小红书视频号
迁移成本非常低
创作者和用户直接过去。
大家都等着你
跟那家视频
你这是收费
我这免费
我就去免费的看了。
你说爱游藤芒
为什么敢这么贴
因为他们是行业共识。
你想看剧
想看综艺
只有那有
你跳到哪一家
都是这样
所以YouTube敢这么做。
那是因为用户走不掉。
B站不敢
是因为用户抬脚就走。
这不是勇气问题
这是处境问题
这是中国互联网公司面临的处境。
中国互联网故事
讲了20多
你心里没点说吗？
还有最后
板上钉钉的一个数字。
李宁在2022年财报会上。
呦呦呦呦呦
被问到这个问题了。
就说你们B站
为什么不贴片
他是这么说的
传统贴片广告
在整个广告市场里的占比。
已经不断下降了
只有3%到5%了。
B站大量视频时长短。
为了这一点收入
破坏播放体验得不偿失。
这句话有道理
对方今天一直在问。
什么大大榴莲
为什么不做
不是傻
人家算过
这就是计算题
不是B站傻
不是他们理想主义。
是他们策算过
这不是空中楼阁
这是实际数字策算的一个理性选择。
朋友们
最后我们抛开刚才说的一切。
我们不讲数据了
我想问各位一件事情。
你还记不记得
你人生中发出去的。
第一条弹幕
它多半是一句废话。
可能就三个字
可能就是一个言文字。
你打完之后
还犹豫了一下
按下了那个发送键。
然后你干了一件
特别傻的事
你把进度条
往回托了一点
倒回去
看看自己这句话
从右边飞到了左边。
感觉不错
而在这个时刻
它已经和其他
几千个陌生人的话。
混在一起了
你甚至分不出
哪一句话是你的
但你就是想再看一遍。
各位
这就是社区
社区不是一群人
在看一个东西而已。
社区是
你能看到成千上万的人。
跨越时间
跨越空间
跟你在这时刻
这个地方
一起相聚
就会了
公明了
所以对方便有今天问。
贴片不就是15秒吗？
YouTube不也这么干吗？
我想说
问题从来不在那15秒。
问题在于
当贴片出现的那一秒。
就是在宣布一件事。
这片土地
不是属于你
和你喜欢的阿卜主的。
它就像一块
不合十一的十倍一样。
就各在那
就让你特别难受
它在时时刻刻提醒你。
这还有另外一个地主。
当所有人意识到
自己只是客人的话。
它就不会再敲出那句弹幕。
他们就不再热烈的。
聚集在一起
他们就只会安静的。
看完这些内容
然后悄然离开
谢谢主席
谢谢对方便
谢谢萧蕾
你看看
这升华了
这升华的多好
虽然是纯别扮演两边。
但是你也能听出来。
他到底支持哪一边。
最后正好是落到这了。
你要是到了反方
也有反方的说法
好吧？
感受了一下
肯定很多朋友
也有共鸣了
对不对
刚才算是一个
简单的促操的表演。
不促操
非常细致
希望对大家有一些启发。
好 我们这一回讲完了。
我们来到第三回
第三回讲什么呢？
我们讲讲
其他那些社区了
移动互联网时代
也有很多成为历史。
或者已经非常小众的社区。
而这里面有好几种命运。
我们可以以五个社区。
作为代表
聊一聊这件事
我们之前聊自杰的时候。
提到过
2011年之后
张一鸣开始做大量的。
做测试
其中最早火的
不是今日头条
叫做搞笑总图
围绕搞笑总图
很快出现了内涵段子。
有提到过
内涵段子
顾名思义
就是搞笑段子的app。
其实在PC时代
也有一个搞笑社区。
求百
第一搞笑社区
求是百科
后来移动时代去哪了。
移动时代
其实他刚开始
也有自己的移动app。
说到求百
求百的创始人王监。
还是产品经理圈
非常知名的早年作者。
他的书解网
也是当年产品经理的。
必读书之一
这属于蜘蛛系列的。
就是蜘蛛之后解网。
后来也出了解网2。
王监老师
巅峰时期
求百的用户超过2亿。
也拿过不少融资
2亿
在当时看
但是这个是注册
但也是非常头部的社区了。
但后来
王监本人的注意力。
不在这方面
求百自己也没有太多迭代。
很快在移动户内
这个激烈竞争下
就没有影响力了
激烈两个字很重要。
确实你也不知道
他怎么着
好像就慢慢的没有东西了。
求百是2022年。
才最终停滞运营的。
自己的停负公告
写了一句话
想年17岁
这也是做一个搞笑社区。
自己终局的一个搞笑的调侃了。
挺有意思
其实在同时期
内涵段子的竞争对手。
除了求百
还有好多
比如说百思不得解。
那个解是姐姐的解。
我们之前有师弟就在那。
是吗？
我们有师弟
我之前用这个
还用了挺多的
这里边也都是一些搞笑图。
什么的
包括也有美女图
当时这些app
都是还挺直男的一些app。
内涵段子
的确是张一鸣自己。
也讲是今日头条的出行。
因为他的推荐算法。
做得太好了
而正因为他做得好。
内涵段子在当时的一众。
竞争对手里面
是非常不得了的
内涵段子的评论区。
当时也非常热闹
甚至成为了
整个内涵段子的重要组成部分。
很多人都不是
看主体内容的
主体内容一般
但是看了热评
就觉得热评更好玩。
这个大家有没有觉得。
有的时候刷小红书。
有这种感受
小红书本身那个笔记。
也就那样
但是下面热评反而更搞笑。
前几位的都是人才。
你们怎么想的
包括我们之前
跟大家讲过多次的。
百度的弱质疤
一样
评论区本身
对于社区来说
也非常重要
它是移动社区
最重要的标志之一。
你做一个社区
是一定要有评论区的。
因为你想嘛？
社区是人跟人之间的关系。
评论区就是
连接人与人之间
最核心的一个途径。
所以说
包括大家聊起播客平台。
我会觉得小宇舟
跟其他的平台比
不太一样
更像社区
也是因为评论区
内涵段子
后来也出现了很多梗。
有一些梗
也是流传在外的
因为有梗
本身也是社区的标志。
比如说天王盖地虎。
小鸡对蘑菇
清风吹阳流
敢问是断油
啤酒小龙虾
断油是一家
还有滴滴滴
这是当时APP的通知音。
后来滴滴
就变成了
内涵段子的断友们。
见面的密码了
很多断友自发组织。
线下聚会
等等
可以说内涵段子
是字节历史上
真的是唯一
特别有社区属性的产品。
2017年
它已经是累计用户。
也超过2亿
月活超过2千万的。
一个大型社区了
这一年
字节也基于后望
给它赞助了快乐大本营。
这个是
给它赞助了
家里面有好多孩子。
今天这个钱花给谁呢？
这个是当年
很多内容APP的统一选择。
小红书
就快乐大本营
去过天天相上
还是快乐大本营
反正他们都去过综艺。
那内涵段子的死掉。
就很戏剧化了
我们就是之前提过一嘴。
是
3月底到4月初
接日头条体系
受到监管压力
央视曝光
火山小视频等
平台有低速内容
4月4日广电总局约谈。
4月9日
接日头条APP
被下架
而一天之后
国家广电总局
直接宣布
永久关停内涵段子。
这个是永久啊？
2018年
后来PPX重新上线。
当然被很多人认为。
是欢魂
但它很难复线
当年内涵段子的影响力。
可想而知
如果不是监管介入。
它会有多大的
一个发展前景
光这个系列
差不多是第三次左右。
会绕不开的
必须要提到它了
虽然说内涵段子没有了。
大家也听这个名字。
包括看内涵段子
早期一些内容
就会觉得好像
挺low的一个社区。
但是很多段友
成了非常好的朋友。
段友们自发组织了。
各种干的活动
甚至有很多段友
还一起组织
去山里给孩子
送衣服
送文具
这个线下文化
也很厉害了
这也是很重要的
一个社区的标志
跟早期毕战
其实也是挺像的
是的
另外一个
Virus CD。
电铝的创始人
黄一孟
电铝是他在大学时候。
做的网站
也是一代人的
很重要的
获取资料的来源了。
后来黄一孟
09年创业做新动网络。
主要是做业游
甚至当时成为
国内首款月流水
破译的业游
业游方面做得很成功。
到了后面
业游这方面
竞争越来越激烈
而到了1516年。
黄一孟发现了一个事情。
这个事情就是
国内的安卓渠道
已经开始有巨大的变化了。
之前可以想象是
曹芒时期
群雄混战时期
那个安卓渠道
也没有什么？
所谓的正儿八点的渠道。
合约机吗？
安卓渠道
安卓就是应用的渠道。
应用渠道
早期就是比较混乱。
大家自己分发
但到后面慢慢的
开始聚集了
已经出现了弯斗甲。
应用宝
出现了百家混战了。
这个可能也很难想象。
当年每个领域
都是百家混战
所以黄一孟发现
渠道这个角度很有机会。
一方面也是防御性的。
如果说
未来这个渠道
都是被第三方的把控了。
我这个业游分发
我这个手游分发
就没有什么太大的利润空间了。
有水不多了
2016年创办了TypeType。
TypeType要做游戏分发。
和游戏社区
想做中国的
开始它是想做中国的Google Play。
那个时候的确还是很有机会。
你说Google Play。
好像觉得说
这个口气有点大
你还能直接做Google的Play。
其实在当年
这个真的是挺有机会的。
大家都在抢
像应用宝当时做的。
也非常非常大了
一度利润空间也是很高的。
那个时候手游主要是连运模式。
什么叫连运
就是抽成
你只要上我的应用商店。
我会给你推的
但到时候你赚的钱。
得分我一些
你知道早年的影运。
它抽成是多少吗？
看来还挺高的
5比5
直接拿一半
这么高
所以它最后这形成了。
一个很恶劣的情况。
就是头部效应
比如说这个
它收钱收的非常狠。
圈圈圈的特别多
商店就会不断的推这个。
其他的就没什么机会。
TypeType。
就绝对看不下去了。
这个市场乱象
我决定要改一下这个分成。
TypeType的分成是多少呢？
给它10%
我不要分成
在我这个平台上
我的商业模式就靠广告。
我就是公正的
去宣发这些游戏
七毛免费小说
一开始
上线就特别重视
编辑推荐
它也是很有社区平台的。
或者内容平台的风格。
主动把供应是
重视玩家的口碑
它是想要做游戏行业的。
当中点评
所以慢慢的评价体系。
和社区氛围也做起来了。
TypeType的评分。
在手游领域也很有公信力了。
TypeType在一周年的时候。
累计用户已超过2000万。
日和超过100万。
平台称
已经有2万家游戏厂商和开发者入驻。
成绩很不错了
当然在这一年
它也面临
所有社区都会面临的问题。
就是监管问题
对它来说
这个还挺麻烦的
因为它不光是有内容。
它还有游戏
而境外的游戏
在那一年被大幅度管控。
很多如果你不走
正常的牌照
分发渠道
你是不能上架的
TypeType就慢慢的。
从安卓应用游戏
分发渠道
转向了社区和评分。
当成自己的主要业务。
2019年TypeType在香港上市。
那个时候
字节米哈游利利斯。
都是它的及时投资者。
这一年TypeType的月活。
达到了1790万。
同比增长19.6%。
2019年全年
TypeType游戏下载量。
到3.5亿
游戏评价累计
从2018年的
700多万条
到1000多万条。
这个
积累下来的资产
是很重要的一个互成合了。
当然
因为其实在国内
大家也都知道
做应用商店
2C的很多机会
已经被大厂
慢慢的都惨失掉了。
然后中国的游戏行业。
比较特殊
所以后来TypeType。
在商业化方面
也开始有新的探索。
开始做2B的服务。
推出了自己的
TDS开发者服务。
这个也在不断的努力。
最新我们看
TypeType的数据的话。
是月活有4000多万。
还在增长
收入目前是在
20亿的党位
还可以
我自己是博尔手游的。
所以感知不明显
但是你如果看到
它的数据你会发现。
TypeType。
依然还是生存
很不错的一个
第二第三提队的
互联网公司的
我们再讲一家
王宁1990年出生。
毕业于北京
信息科技大学
计算机专业
大学时期
他做过很多实习
其中比较关键的是。
在原题库
后来他反复提到过。
原题库这段经历
让他接触
从产品运营
到项目录地的一整套流程。
所以后来他决定创业了。
王宁在
这不是抛马特那个王宁。
2014年9月
王宁创办了Keep。
按照王宁自己的描述。
他自己就有亲身经历。
大学毕业前
因为感情问题
因为个人状态问题。
开始减肥
半年时间
从180斤
减到128斤
你看看
问题是
当时他就发现了
如果一个完全
不懂健身的人
我忽然突发欣赏减肥。
网上
当然你可以搜到很多信息。
但这信息完全不成体系。
非常碎片
百度贴吧健身论坛。
知乎视频网站
各种各样的
有让你深蹲的
有让你举帖的
有让你HIT的
有给你影视建议的。
等等很复杂
不好判断
所以他刚开始推出Keep。
定位非常简单
就一个Slogan。
移动健身教练
但是跟很多
其他工具类的产品不一样。
他们一开始就关注到社区了。
数据积累
打卡
这些社区互动
让训练本身变成了。
一个不是说我只跟着。
这个工具去做训练。
而是他有了反馈的。
这么一个行为
所以他就有了
社区属性了
2016年Keep注册用户。
达到3000万
当时月火已经1000多万了。
2017年Keep宣布。
注册用户已经破译。
接下来Keep就开始激烈的。
拓展业务了
他把所有跟健身有关的。
基本上都做了一遍。
什么运动服装
瑜伽垫
弹力带
雅灵
提制衬
跑步机
手环
走步机
动态单车
什么健康食品等等。
以及他也做了
线下空间
团客健身房
Keepland。
摊子铺得很大
作为一个线上社区。
做了这么多线下的东西。
这么终的东西
疫情来的时候
对于Keep来说。
当然也是大幅提升。
整体数据
大家都在家里健身。
你的门都出不了了。
那就靠它了
2019年月火是2000多万。
到了2022年
已经到了3600多万了。
就是靠疫情
融资方面
21年完成了3.6亿美元。
F文融资
到后面22年
从结构上来看
它自由品牌
运动产品的收入
占比51.4%
会员占比40.4%。
也就是说
它那个线下的那些。
比较高
但是
它毕竟是收入超过。
利润方面
它就是一直亏损
没有赚到钱
而最神奇的
让Keep终于养媒吐气。
自己的形式的
这个商业模式
2021年出现了。
居然跟另一个
王宁的那家公司
泡泡马特
非常类似
你别说还真是
叫做实体奖牌
这个奖牌
当时我看新闻的时候。
我还以为它就是一个。
怎么说
谈话一线
或者说一个体量很小的。
品牌营销
方向的这么一个产品。
结果没想到
体积这么大
数据上非常可怕
首先讲讲这是什么？
就是你在Keep里面。
报名一场比赛
支付几十元报名费。
只要在规定时间里。
完成这个运动
你可能是跑5公里。
跑10公里
或者某线运动
我就是直接给你记奖牌。
而Keep又把这个奖牌。
和大量的IP联名。
Hello Kitty。
拉比小新
游戏动漫
就跟泡泡马特一样。
可以说卖爆了
对 卖 你得花钱。
很多人
就刚才说的
它也不是很贵
它就几十块钱
很多人跑完
就有巨大的正反馈。
我本来健身
我就想要激励
但是你那个假的会章。
虚你的会章
好像就不如实体的。
就带进
很多人跑完
就有巨大的正反馈。
有了之后
还能拍照发小红书。
看到别人的小红书。
你自己又想搞一个。
它的意义感
真的就强了很多
公开资料显示
Keep的虚拟赛事收入。
19年是1400万。
20年是3300万。
21年是7000万。
22年3.3亿
顺着这个业务
也就是在他数据
非常好的时候
2023年7月
Keep终于上市了。
具体的一些
我们就不展开了
到今天你可以说
Keep没有大起大落。
也没有说像大家理解。
因为现在很多公开新闻。
和公开的讨论里面。
比较少见Keep。
但你看到的数据
依然还是还可以的。
还是在踏踏实实
做生意的样子
收入看是16亿的收入。
25年盈利大概2000多万。
这算是第一次全年盈利。
就是终于转过来了。
也是一个正常经营的公司了。
正现金流了
我们再说一家
2011年网易内部幅画的。
中国版的Tumbler。
Tumbler解释一下。
他一般被认为这个概念叫。
轻博客
什么叫轻博客
过去的博客很长
博客主要是写文章。
然后微博又主要是。
强调社交关系
你的关注
什么强调快
轻博客就是硬插出来的。
一个介于中间的
你可以写一个文章。
但这个文章不会很长。
同时大家会因为这个文章。
关注你
也能通过发这些东西。
互相交流
可能更多关注的是内容。
而不是事
或者说时事
或者说新闻这些
是
他的内容属性又会比微博更强一些。
这一类当时是很多的。
也是很卷的
虽然今天我们说
不太存在轻博客
或者说轻博客
被小黄叔替代了吧？
但当年是非常多的。
像点点网
我们之前提过的
盛大做过
新浪做过
人人做过
凤凰做过
大家都做过轻博客。
什么新浪轻
人人小战
凤凰快博
然后网易
就腐化了一个
自己的轻博客
叫做lofter。
lofter
刚开始还是很文艺的。
很多设计师用
他们用来展示作品。
你看这个作品展示和。
强调自己个人
主业这个模式
他就很适合
用轻博客的方式
因为他的作品
可能不太像
过去博客一样
这个篇幅需要很长。
我可能就一个简单的作品。
我就跟大家发一下。
交流一下
但是中国的轻博客。
整个行业都没有太做起来。
到2015年
基本上也就
都关掉了
因为这还涉及到说。
当时公众号
已经都做起来了
这还能坚持到15年。
已经是比下一次的。
想象要久了
lofter在这个时候。
开始转型
扶持二次元和同仁。
结果效果非常好
你通过轻博客
这种方式去组织
就发现同仁群体
用的是最顺畅的
比如说这里面
有一个标签功能
Tag
加Tag对于他们来说。
非常有帮助
比如说你喜欢全职高手。
而且你喜欢的很细。
你喜欢的是这里面的鱼黄。
你不需要进什么Tag。
你也不需要去
通过作者关注
不需要通过作品
哪个入口
只要搜鱼黄
都能搜得到
它就直接定位到
跟今天我们用小红书的Tag。
是类似的
大批创作者
在其他平台环境变化之后。
签入lofter。
成为
二次元和同仁文化的。
重要根据地
再加上Cp文化开始盛行了。
那个时候一纪年
lofter就开始热闹起来。
大家都进去找
我看到一个喜欢的作品。
我特别想看看
这两人如果在一块会怎么样。
那你就去lofter找。
一定有
什么人在一块都有。
然后慢慢有了
自己的社区文化
比如说在lofter那儿。
创作者叫太太
为什么叫太太
本来大家是叫大胆。
大胆是大家知道
可以理解
他说你比大胆还大一点。
这么个意思
下面加个太太
你是太爷
老师
然后创作
叫产粮
独作品
叫吃粮
你快点产吧？
粮不够吃了
都有一套话书体系。
他们就有一个亚文化了。
但是这个亚文化
说起来
它就也会有一定的风险。
它的风险
可想而知
后来就会出现在
这个饭圈里边
2020年出现了。
肖赚粉丝针对
同仁内容和AO3的举报行动。
AO3算是
全球最大的同仁网站了。
直接被抢了
然后lofter。
也顺便被举报了
直到下架
lofter一段时间是下架了。
不能让他跟他在一块。
吵什么？
就是发生了这种冲突。
不能接受不能忍受。
后来
lofter也一直在调整。
2021年
lofter一方面在泛化兴趣范围。
别只关注同仁
别只关注儿祖源这些。
所以兴趣角度上面。
一直在推动其他的一些方向。
另外一方面
也在做产业链
比如说做打赏
做付费内容
做会员体系
做IP开发
所以
作为清博科时期
留下来的活化时
他今天还活得好好的。
只不过他
因为是在网易体系内。
他也没有什么独立上市。
我们很多数据和资料。
也比较少看到了
是
再加上确实有点垂。
那我们再说一家
林凡1980年生日。
98年进入清华计算机器。
他属于非常典型的。
中国互联网
第一代技术经营
获得了清华本科
特等奖学金
毕业之后
进入王小川的搜狗早期团队。
参与搜索
输入法 浏览器等业务。
后来去了大街网
他做过技术合伙人。
到2012年
林凡决定自己创业。
要做跟人脉相关的产品。
他后来解释过
为什么想要做人脉产品。
他讲过两个很私人的案例。
一个是03年母亲患病。
他要找医生
但是发现自己身边。
都是互联网同学者。
介绍来介绍去
不知道去哪儿找
07年孩子出生之后。
想要找教育资源
但是也是找来找去。
不知道去哪儿找老师。
就了解一下信息
都不知道怎么聊
所以离职要创业之后。
他先做了一个网站。
叫做淘有网
找朋友
你是淘宝吗？
我淘有吗？
人脉搜索引擎
未来理想情况下
你搜入关键词
比如说新浪 广告 销售。
未来理想情况下
应该搜小鹏
这什么东西
对 这是小鹏
有没有在小鹏公司的。
理想情况下
就是你只要搜几个关键词。
某个公司
某个公司的什么岗位。
能搜出这个人了
你跟他能社交
他能替你找到这个人。
但是大家能想象一下。
这不太现实
在中国还是没有这个土壤。
或者说大家也没有太多的动力。
把自己的真实信息。
那么实名地传上去。
你找我干啥呢？
你如果说
对我有什么好处呢？
如果说提供行家的一些建议的话。
后来也有在行这样的产品。
它就会更面向服务一些。
但你如果说只面向人脉的。
它其实不太好形成一个平台循环的。
就是两边动力不对等。
林凡后来又想说
那你要场景
你要需求
那就做了一个恋爱产品。
叫秘密 寻秘的密。
那是个恋爱产品
寻秘的密
不是追秘
林凡就一直觉得说。
一定要通过二度人漫。
去做这个社交
什么意思呢？
就是他的恋爱产品。
更多强调的就是
你在上面注册之后。
这是你朋友吧？
你朋友的朋友
肯定跟你价值观
或者各方面是比较像的。
所以通过朋友的朋友谈恋爱。
还有这层思考呢？
他就是想用二度人漫去拓展。
这个思路还真没想到过。
但这个也没有特别顺利。
直到后来他想说
朋友的朋友不光谈恋爱。
朋友的朋友还能找工作。
又回到人脉
2013年10月。
卖卖上线了
卖卖早先确实有点像领营。
中国领营
因为他这里面强调的。
不就是你自己的身份。
我能通过身份找到你吗？
这样他的供需不就相对匹配了吗？
比朋友网还要合理一点。
我是要找工作的
他是要招聘的
结果就没想到就走不好偏了呢？
然后融资刚开始是非常顺利的。
13年A轮500万美元。
14年B轮2000万美元。
16年卖卖已经有2000万注册用户。
200万的日和
B轮之后估值超过1亿。
林凡公开表示
卖卖在16年前
后已经实现盈亏平衡。
早期的商业模式
主要包括广告会员招聘。
招聘是个刚需
刚才也说了
他愿意付费
他也合理商业化上。
17年C轮融资达到7500万美元。
林凡当时公开表示。
19年咱要去美国上市了。
18年8月
D轮又融到了2亿美元。
达到巅峰
而这个过程当中
他的日和是咧咧咧的往上穿。
为啥呢？
因为小蕾说的
大家对她的认知是觉得。
好像大家上卖卖
就是为了吐槽的
刚说的所谓的跑偏。
为啥呢？
因为卖卖有一个职场的匿名区。
而匿名区成了卖卖最重要的日和来源。
甚至成了很多媒体爆料的引用来源。
现在有一些过渡到小红书了。
有些人跑到小红书爆料。
但当时主要就是卖卖。
卖卖有谁说了
那个公司出什么事了。
但是这里面有真有假。
有的是造谣
但相当一部分
可能当时也有大量的引用的。
而这之后
就在他容地伦的时候。
也引发了很多纠纷。
比如说北京市网信办公安机关联合约谈卖卖。
指出这个板块存在各种防不谣言。
侮辱誹谤
侵犯他人名誉和隐私等问题。
要求直接关闭匿名区。
这就大问题了
后来卖卖关闭了匿名区。
但是推出了职严区。
职业的职
说话的话
这个算是后台使命。
比如说你有人来查。
我还是能查到是谁的。
但是前台依然是匿名。
卖卖是很特殊的社区。
匿名的板块
当然也是很多职场人。
刷八卦吃瓜的论坛水区。
别的论坛可能也没有。
在这儿聊得这么垂的。
互联网茶水间
当然也是各个公司的。
人力和公关咬牙切齿的地方。
说到卖卖真的是要疯。
不知道该怎么弄
没办法
八卦和谣言大量的都是共存的。
你当然有一些
大家是为了吃瓜
但是这里面有些
没有特别确定的事。
它就已经爆出来了。
有一些人他也面临。
非常多的恶意誹謗。
有的负面对公司
包括对个人影响都非常大。
我之前就经常刷到。
有的同事被造谣
甚至还有容貌羞辱的。
容貌侮辱的
你说这东西怎么说。
这匿名有些人性的恶。
就都出来了
它是容易自身恶的。
这是慢慢取现
救国的一个侧面了。
后来2021年
领英宣布关闭
中国大陆版本的社交功能。
陆续推出中国了
卖卖在这个时候
宣布拥有1.1亿注册用户。
招聘服务连接了
700多万的职场人。
第三方Quest Mobile。
给出的21年
卖卖的月活有300多万。
当然你可以说
它肯定不算是
第一梯队的社区
但是一直是有月活的。
后来卖卖的
也推出了自己
新的商业模式的功能。
就是对比奥BOSS执聘的。
卖卖高聘
而卖卖高聘在AI这一波。
又算是赶上了一波。
因为之前招聘这个方向。
在移动互联网浪潮过去之后。
一直是往下走的
冷下去的
但现在AI来了
又热上去了
大家不管是关于AI的讨论。
职场的交流
还是说职场的招聘。
越来越多了
还没有下排桌的那些。
就能接住这波
林凡最近一些公开的表达里面。
反复强调过
80%的AI人才就在卖卖。
他是这么说的
大家都会上卖买的。
以上讲了好多
我们再讲最后一个。
2014年
叶西东从Google离职回国创业。
拉了一圈朋友
2015年3月上线。
最早他做的是
RSS订阅工具
叫做基于兴趣的信息提醒工具。
拿了连续好几轮融资。
但这个时候
你可以说
它还是一个信息工具。
你订阅了一些事件。
订阅了谁更新了微博。
订阅了什么？
哪个媒体发的新闻等等的这些。
在当时
通常被认为
跟今日头条算一个赛道的。
你说还能跟今日头条比。
主要是那个时候
今日头条还没有那么厉害。
但是早期有大量的信息自信工具。
市面上有很多
因为它是要获取信息。
而且是基于兴趣的信息提醒工具。
因为要提醒
这是即刻获取
所以就叫即刻了
名字是这么来的
但工具它有一个问题。
因为它是订阅逻辑。
它跟今日头条不一样。
它是可以刷完
推荐算法
我们之前讲过
厉害的地方
今日头条抖音
无线流
它废的流可以无线刷。
但订阅是你关心的东西。
你可能就关心这几件事。
你刷完了也就给它关了。
对于产品来说
对于平台方来说
就有点头疼
所以它想做调整
我们前面反复提到了。
评论区是很重要的。
所以真正作为即刻的社区出行。
是2015年5月出现的。
因为它加入了评论区。
到了2017年
即刻又增加了
用户自建主题推荐业。
点赞动态
转发个人主业这些功能。
用户能在动态里点赞和评论了。
它已经有点微博的意思了。
只不过它跟微博差别很大的。
微博主要是关注人和账号。
这主要是关注内容话题。
比如产品经理的日常。
这种话题
围绕不同的话题
慢慢的
它也有了贴巴的意思了。
这里面就真的开始。
产生了社区氛围
所以也出现了一些说法。
即刻的网友就自称极有。
极有们见面就自称面极。
到了2018年
主题变成了圈子
而且也逐步从
原来的爬取账外的信息。
和账外的提醒
变成了内部
自己生产内容的UGC社区。
它解决了一个很重要的问题。
因为这两年
我们前面讲今日头条的时候。
也提到过
你爬人家外恋
人家就给你关掉了。
所以你靠这个提醒。
你提醒的都是账外的东西。
你是做不长的
所以慢慢变成了
自己生产
自己消费的一个社区了。
而这一年
也是所谓大量的
极客like产品出现的时候。
比如说2018年。
腾讯就推出过一款。
叫做立之
不是那个立之
是立刻知道
立之的一个提醒app。
当时还被大量的
极客用户指出说
还是个产品逻辑功能。
很多设计
就直接像素抄袭
结果这事闹大了
第二天产品下架
几天之后
腾讯宣布
有3000万美元C轮。
给极客做投资
总之该不觉得
还得不觉得
那1819年算是极客。
最辉煌的时候了
而2019年7月12日。
极客突然停止服务。
这次停伏停了多久。
333天
停了小一年
其实当时能不能回来。
大家都心里没底的。
最后很不容易
一年就回来了
而在这一年当中
这一年很重要
还是说的烟织非服。
这一年当中
那团队没事干
另外一方面
是你也得自救
是
所以就推出了大量的。
想点新折
新的APP
包括谈恋爱的成
成字的成
包括commit面积。
包括快鸟返利
这是一个电商返利类的产品。
包括极事多
包括pingpo。
包括小宇舟
有了
小宇舟
2020年3月26日上线。
最早的版本
第一版本是非常简陋的。
一个podcast工具。
而且在当时看
我们今天当然是
后怎么说小宇舟都可以。
在当时看
其实大家也会觉得。
好像没什么机会了。
喜马拉雅
清廷
栗枝
王云月
这些都是已经做成的。
都很急了
没做成的音频工具。
太多了
包括苹果波克
也是专做波克的
也很多年了
一方面是有这么多大厂。
你凭什么可以
一方面是波克
在中国这么多年了。
它也没火
这没有水花
大小宇舟还真做起来了。
包括刚才说的评论区。
后来加入之后
它就有了社区氛围了。
而且它做了一个
非常天才的设计
这是可能小宇舟历史上。
最重要的设计
时间戳评论
它跟弹幕
对于视频的意义是一样的。
疫区通工了
它变成了在音频领域。
非常核心的一个功能。
让大家能够
基于某个时间点去做评论。
能了解来了
这个之前所有的波克产品。
都是没有的
再就是跟之前说的。
很多社区一样
小宇舟在前期
非常在意编辑推荐。
所以他也建立了
一定的社区品位
2021年
小宇舟已经被公认为。
中文波克回温的核心推手。
很多大厂也都在快速推进。
都在上了自己的App。
然后很快就下了
这一年也是一个交叉。
原来寄予厚望
也更大众的
中道C轮的即刻社区。
变成了一个小众的圈子。
变成了创投圈
AI领域产品经理。
技术们
互联网从业者
自己讨论的一个小社区了。
它从当年200多万。
日火的巅峰影音往下掉了不少。
现在应该日火都没有到百万了。
而小宇舟反而越来越破圈。
平时的日火都是
几百万
上千万的量级
直到今年
波克在跟2020年。
小宇舟刚成绩的时候。
也完全不可同日耳语了。
而正是因为即刻才有了小宇舟。
正是因为有了小宇舟。
相当一部分朋友
才能在声波里跟我们相遇。
有感谢前面所有的。
这些思思旅旅
剩下的社区
确实没法展开说太多了。
虽然手指头数出来。
那种大的社区就那么几个。
但是大家有印象的。
好像注册过
在上面交过朋友的社区。
还是挺多的
你真还脑袋想不好想。
但一提你会知道
比如说网易云音乐。
虽然是一个音乐工具。
但它显然也有社区的属性。
因为它也有评论区。
而且网易云音乐的评论区。
也出现了压文化
什么网易云 意欲的欲。
什么凌晨12点
伤感文学等等这些。
什么值得买
这个也获得很久
它是PCS它2010年就出现的。
移动端2012年上线。
之前我个人是逛的挺多的。
因为它上面
确实有很多很有价值的分析。
就是怎么省钱的办法等等。
但这些东西
现在基本上也就在小红书上找了。
最后也是搞笑内容。
神评论 话题 社区。
跟当时很多同类
那一段段子是接近的。
最后本身的意思就是指。
微博转发的时候
不是一条一条转发。
但大家转发都是因为最右边那一条。
也就是热屏 屏的特别好。
所以大家就会叫最右。
哦 逻辑是这么来的。
最后就是热屏
所以它本身强调的。
也是评论区这个理念。
到今天最后还活着。
另外包括Soul。
这个也算是一个社区了。
当然它也有很强的。
陌生社交的属性
它弱化真实身份和照片。
每个人先是一个Avata。
这个Avata在通过性格。
兴趣去匹配别人
今天当然Soul也活得好好的。
还有类似的
有很强的社区成分的。
社交产品
Nice,Same,Blood,Less Park等等。
我们都没法一一展开说了。
我这些一个O的都没有。
后面这四个都没听过。
是 有的你听过也有点奇怪了。
因为它太垂了
大家知道的朋友
可能就知道是为什么？
还比如说像默默探探等等这些。
它这里面也有强烈的社区的成分。
还有一些它会跟轻薄刻结合。
比如说当年的E，Mono，足迹，片刻，简书等等。
还有简书的事呢？
匿名类的社区也有很多。
麦麦刚才是职场匿名的。
比如说无密，一贯等等。
还有做校园市场的。
比如超级课程表
这是校园的社交APP。
按照兴趣化分也有很多。
美食有下厨房
足球有董球地
摄影有图虫和POCO。
家庄有好好住
游戏有小黑盒、机盒。
还有像数码和工具相关的少数派。
像我们之前提过的。
宝宝树、妈妈网、拉妈帮等等。
都算是一个大类
还有包括付费空间的知识星球。
之前是小密圈
它是解决这个的一个社区。
说到知识星球
可能就得提到像
分达、德道、西马拉雅。
这些当年的斯拉天王。
刚说的在行也不太一样。
也有 其实都有
社区的成分
还有包括你像
咸鱼、转转、多抓鱼。
那是不是也都有社区的成分。
它都有基于兴趣
大家要在里面交流。
讨论的这个成分
而这里面的社区
有很多已经彻底关闭了。
有的还在
但是大部分都比较小众了。
这两期社区
我们差不多聊到这。
聊完之后
我们可以总结几个特点。
第一就是
小众垂直社区大量都不存在了。
那是不是代表着
人跟人不交流了呢？
当然不是
换到小红书了吗？
换到了微信小红书。
B站这些地方
你没必要单独给
每个需求下一个APP了。
这个也是符合人性的。
人性懒惰的
我在一个地方
就能看到最全的东西。
创作者在一个地方。
就能发各种东西
第二就是社区的商业化。
从前面的这些案例。
也都能感受到
都存在各种各样的问题。
社区不像有的产品。
可以直接非常通畅的。
引入广告的模式
我们之前
聊中国互联网的
这些大厂都聊过
百度阿里自洁
根本上说都是广告公司。
他们的广告也很好。
融合
你想象一下
只要不做得太过分。
不太会影响
自己本来的产品和服务的。
但是社区不一样
社区的广告
的确就像前面
我们的辩论的那个部分一样。
很多人会认为
它破坏社区的氛围。
甚至会改变社区的内容。
它会让大家变味
所以大家都在探索新的方式。
探索出来的
有的活得很好
探索不出来的
可能也就慢慢的推出。
历史舞台了
第三就是
社区也存在破圈的詛咒。
你刚开始做一个社区。
大家都是社团爱好者。
甚至刚开始只有几百几千人。
是非常温馨的
很紧密的
大家连接很紧密
互相都认识
氛围是特别好维护的。
但是社区一旦变大。
它就会产生很多剧烈的冲突。
老用户是很讨厌的。
讨厌氛围的转变
新用户也讨厌老用户。
一老卖牢
他们这些内部梗
我们也听不懂什么意思。
整天就扯这些有的没的。
那这个过程当中
怎么平衡各方的需求。
作为平台来说
让大家都能接受
难度是非常大的
原则上当然也有解决办法。
你就是想办法
把不同的群体尽量区隔开来。
通过关注关系也好。
通过推荐算法也好。
能一定程度实现
但是也是有难度的。
说到推荐算法和关注。
我们说第四个问题。
好的推荐算法
极大的提升了找到同类的效率。
但是推荐算法
依然是围绕内容
而不是围绕人的
这个里面逻辑就很值得琢磨了。
它不是让固定的人群。
在一个场合反复相遇。
讨论沟通
它是会削弱社区氛围的。
最后我消费的
更多的我来这
我主要消费的是内容。
作为一个独立的个体。
跟内容产生联系
而更少的跟其他的人。
产生联系
这中间的平衡
它也是一个两难的问题。
第五就是我们之前提到过的。
内容平台和社区平台。
还不是天然
就偶和在一块的
你像字节这么多年。
一直想做社区
就是很难做起来
前面我们也讲过这个逻辑了。
阿里也是
但同样的
我们再说回来
独立社区失去的是。
现在你很难在移动互联网时。
它在长成一个旁人大物了。
你可能得通过完全创新的形式。
现在可能小红书必占。
这些平台已经处于。
一个成熟的阶段了。
但是反过来说
只要有一批忠实的用户在。
一个小社区也还能好好的活着。
像前面说的极客
他也活得挺好的
一个小社区现在也未必。
必须成为一个下一个小红书。
必须融资大高举高达。
必须资大作强
不一定
你只要有一批忠实的用户。
还有一种能够维持运营的方式。
你可能就是
一小凑人的精神家园。
也能做下去
多少的有点互成合。
不要被那些大的社区。
随随便便一挥手就割掉了命。
而社区也将会永远是。
所有人使用互联网产品的。
一个重要需求
这也是互联网本身。
最早做出来的时候。
很多互联网早期的先驱。
他们想要实现的一个愿景。
这个需求是永远不会消失的。
社区Bring People Together。
参考单立人的Slogan。
喜剧Bring People Together。
社区也是Bring People Together。
播客也是Bring People Together。
感谢这些社区的陪伴。
那么到节目最后了。
我们再聊两句
网易悠悠远程
再次感谢网易悠悠远程。
对本期节目的赞助。
如果你想长期AI Coding。
不想把自己锁在电脑前。
又或者经常出差
需要长期远程办公的话。
又或者人在外面
或者旅游在外
有临时办公
或者首养
我就想打个游戏了。
还是挺推荐大家
常备悠悠远程的
速度快 效果稳
还有很多搭配的小功能。
而且是免费的
真的 挺好用的
感兴趣可以到Shownotes里面。
能直接下载
或者个大平台直接搜索。
悠悠远程
试一下不吃亏
那在最后呢？
我们中国互联网系列。
也终于迎来了
卫生
最后应该就差几期了。
准备在几期内就结束了。
而且回顾过去看
我搜了一下
现在还日活比较高的。
日活破译的这些互联网产品。
基本上到咱们这期讲完。
差不多就过了一遍了。
覆盖到了
有一些可能没有特别展开提到的。
比如说像协成
高德地图这些
但是基本上
该讲到的都讲完了。
大家也可以松口气了。
有一些朋友觉得
这个讲得是有点久了。
我自己也感觉讲得有点久了。
其实还好
对于很多人朋友来说。
我们看一个大数据。
大部分的朋友
都还是期待的一个状态。
另外就是整体的风格。
讲到后面
确实我自己个人
有一些私心是想要。
把它拆得更清楚
所以这个讲述的部分。
和论证的部分
会多一些
没有之前那么搞笑的。
或者说
稍微有点枯燥的
这个也跟大家提一下。
希望大家还是回头想想。
觉得好像这个道理。
有一些启发能有帮助。
是
我们俩一直都在纠结。
但是又放不下的东西。
好
那最后提一下片尾曲。
今天用的片尾曲
也确实是非常私人的感受。
讲社区的时候
我就想用这个片尾曲去结尾了。
一开始就想到了
因为我高中的时候。
那个时候
生活非常艰难
作为一个山东的高中生。
学习很痛苦
精神上也一直很压抑。
非常难受
然后有一个朋友
我一直在跟他通信。
这个朋友
我到今天都没有见过。
就是纯笔友
你看看
也是朋友的朋友
就真的是朋友的朋友。
然后跟他不断地写信。
当时要是有卖卖
早就接触上了
一直没有见上面
然后这个成为了
我度过那段时间
非常重要的一个精神寄托。
精神寄托
太重要的精神寄托了。
他给你推荐了一首歌。
而中间有一封信里。
他给我抄了一份完整的歌词。
这个完整的歌词名字叫铜泪。
他说我们这种
大家能聊到一块的。
就是铜泪
而遇到一个铜泪
太不容易了
刘飞这一周
含燕子量有点高
虽然值得
铜泪
来吧？
来 又请
我狼狈
路边的座位
他空着在等谁
我拉住时间
他却不理会
有没有别人
一样很想被安慰
风停了又吹
我忽然想起谁
一天亮了又黑
我又过了好几岁
心乱了又灰
世界有时候孤单的。
很需要另一个铜泪。
爱收了又给
我们都不太完美
梦做了又碎
我们有几次机会
拒绝不朽的为什么爱。
又稀少又昂贵
歌听完了
我估计这期
应该不少人会留言。
我就想知道
刘飞老师
那个笔友
现在还有没有连
真的没见
我都不知道他长什么样。
这是真的是属于那个年代的。
一种非常特殊的朋友关系。
大家精神上很多共鸣。
但你没见过这个人。
我觉得跟年代确实有关。
我不知道跟时期有没有关。
比如说现在的年轻人。
上高中还会不会有笔友。
反正像我上高中的时候。
也会有写信的习惯。
更多是跟年代
还是跟年龄有关
大家也可以反馈一下。
而且这首歌比较特殊的。
这也是很少见的一种体验。
我是对歌词非常熟悉了之后。
才听到这首歌的
我再不断的看歌词。
那个时候没有条件。
你得回家下歌
那时候没有时间
打开电脑下歌
你就在那看歌词
看歌词
这歌词很熟了
就像是诗一样
后来你再听到
他唱出来又是不一样的感受。
对很多人来说
我们显然是少有这种体验。
是啊 就是当年
超歌词的那个年代。
重新认识了一个老朋友的感觉。
好 那来到彩蛋环节。
念的评论是
212期曾经的精神角落。
我们聊的豆瓣
蜘蛛铁吧和虎铺
这一期收到了历史上。
最多的评论数之一。
是 大家一千多条。
很多朋友留言
然后因为一千多条。
我就让AI帮我整理了一下。
对于这四个网站
大家都有很多各种各样的。
情感和回忆
你想豆瓣
大家通常提到的
就是自己的精神家园。
大家都会提到这么多年。
仍然不愿意卸载
甚至有的时候不太打开了。
也不愿意卸载
因为这十几年的记录。
非常非常重要了
它是不会丢掉的
现在也确实是
没有那么大不要
而知乎最重要的价值。
是降低信息差
有很多来自小城
来自普通家庭的听友。
表示说我早年间
身边没有这些渠道。
家境就是比较普通。
不是什么知识分子家庭。
所以早期了解
专业 行业 留学。
包括程序员
进入互联网等等
改变选科
转专业甚至出国的路径。
改变自己人生
都是通过知乎的
而T8了解了
更多的是自己爱好。
兴趣 驱动的
追一些明星 乐队。
看一些小说 游戏。
找资源
行程的这种回忆
而虎铺
那就很分裂了
很多人上来就
不是很客气
这论坛已经完蛋了。
对于它的社区内容。
也不是很认可
对 但有一些朋友。
也是觉得虎铺
承载了自己过去
很重要的一些记忆。
从提到评次来看
的确逗办是遥遥领先的。
逗办有四百多条
一共我们才一千条。
四百多条提到了逗办。
一百多条提到了知乎。
六十多条提到了虎铺。
四十多条提到了T8。
三十多条提到了小红书。
再往下一次是
公众号 微博 抖音 天涯 毕章和极客。
还有两个提到了极客。
你看不少朋友
采中了今天的话题。
当然上期末尾
其实也预告到了
其中一家了
接下来念几条
金黄的评论
首先 这位他说
听到这 忍不住留言了。
播客主APP第一版。
是我跟另一个同事。
一起做的交互和UI设计。
想起来还有点小骄傲。
做完这几个版本
我就离职了
我很喜欢逗办
它是我职业生涯的启蒙地。
认识了一大批优秀的朋友。
当时为什么要离开呢？
也跟刘飞前面讲的有关。
在做逗办主APP之前的。
很长一段时间
逗办的移动转型是失败的。
一年多的时间
做了太多太多的尝试。
关我自己参与的
就有逗办小组
逗办电影
逗办阅读
还有几个TES服装。
没有上线的APP。
一开始有新东西做。
对于一个年轻人来讲。
是比较兴奋的
但时间一长觉得不对劲。
没有了成就感
进而产生了迷茫
离开逗办这么多年。
它还安静地固守它的地盘。
确实挣不到钱
但也挺好
只希望在逗办
坚持出新的那些老伙计们。
老伙计们
能舒适安心
不被浮躁的
互联网红流冲击淹没。
一支片
老伙计们就很一支片。
要这么说起来的话。
突然又让我刚想到了。
那个小红书
八个五年
在对比逗办老伙计。
确实会有一些
显明的不一样的地方。
像温道
这位朋友说
这一段太有功名了。
我一二年入学
一六年毕业
大学四年里
我在知乎上读了大量。
关于科技 媒体 技术行业。
和程序员
职业发展的讨论
这些内容
开阔了我的视野
让我第一次知道
这个世界上
原来有这么多不同的行业。
也逐渐明白了
他们各自在做什么？
知乎还解答了
我当时很多困惑
最终促使我下令决心。
从物理学
转行去做程序员
在此之前
我和我的家人
对这些行业
义务所知
没有人能给我提供指讨。
关于转专业
读计算机职业选择。
未来的发展方向
所有信息
都是我自己在知乎上。
一点点
搜集和拼凑起来的。
我通过知乎了解
到出国留学这条路。
开始主动搜集
申请信息
向有经验的人请教。
还提前认识了
不少在硅谷工作的。
工程师前辈
你看这
这才是卖买
这才是淘有
可以说
从大学到入学
到转专业
读计算机
出国留学
申请到离县的学校。
最后在硅谷工作
整个过程中
我一直从知乎获取。
信息 经验和启发。
特别感谢
那个时期的知乎
虽然现在已经很少刷了。
也确实觉得
今天的信息
变得过于庞杂
但在当时
它真的改变了我的人生。
特别是讲完这期之后。
你再来听这个留言。
你在前后对比
现在大家在干这个事。
你会去哪个平台
刚好有一个惊喜的对照。
延二UngDream说。
2006年注册豆瓣。
豆瓣已经是20年纪念了。
2007年在豆瓣。
做了一个小组
叫修学辞职去旅行。
组员一度达25万。
这是25万大组的版主。
为此上了几个电视台节目。
被批评三观不正
为此在苏州开了一家。
青年旅社出了一本书。
甚至这几年做民宿。
露营地也都和豆瓣。
营营有关系
通过豆瓣
认识了太多
到现在还联络的好友。
旅行者行走四十国。
音乐人朱紫界
作家卫斯校等等
另外
贡献豆烈书评
影评月评若干
小说近百万字
还有小说近百万字。
你看
刚才说的是知乎改变人生的。
这位有时候豆瓣改变人生的。
深度体验的
不光是被动
这是非常主动的
这个就是社区真的。
连接人和人了
他自己认识了很多。
可能是医生的好朋友了。
青耳亲听别人说
18年豆瓣用户
13年
第一次独自旅行
去成都
做了形成计划
到豆瓣小组问
路线是否合适
得到很多网友的帮助。
还有一位当地的网友。
给我做向导
还请我看了
陈主生演唱会
后来给了我很多
游泳的旅行信息
我表示感谢
他就说
他想着帮助游客
了解他的家乡
是一件开心的事
以后去别的地方旅游。
也会得到同样的帮助的。
带客之道
臼司的带客之道
这就是
冰客之一
奥德塞了
奥德塞他就带客之道。
放到现在的网络
和社会环境
可能很难想象
但早期的很多小组。
都会有这样的
真实的信息
我自己也会分享
自学日语的经验等等。
后面都是人味
所以因此
结交了好多网友
参加了几个豆瓣的活动。
有的人现在还有联系。
好环见当年的网络环境。
和互联网后面
实实在在的人
没好
为什么没好
很感慨
这就说到最近
那个诺兰电影奥德塞里面。
他的带客之道
其实在古代
这个带客之道
是一个神圣的义乎。
不像今天
这是你的礼貌
或者说你仁善
做这个事
在当年你不这么做。
你会被神惩罚的
所以大家都得这么做。
奥德塞本身援助
包括这个电影
这里面对于这个逻辑。
有很多分析和拆解。
所以说到这也挺感慨的。
早年大家真的是我帮您。
你就帮我
当然了
更多的也是希望
这个
它可以跟更多人的年龄有关。
而不要强行绑定在年代上。
这是我们的希望
说白了就是
因为那个年代过去了。
很多曾经美好的事。
将来会越来越少
对
徐哥哥
老朋友又说了
我一度还算是
豆瓣东西的KOL。
我以前贡职的公司。
做了豆瓣东西的竞品。
当然比他们早多了。
我们当时对标的是。
国外的Fancy。
这个产品模式
没做起来的原因在于。
基本上盈利模式
就是靠做逃客专用金。
没人想过
怎么把内容本身
做得更有价值
我思当时想的
赚钱方式是做盲盒。
远在2012年
当然那个时候
还不叫盲盒
但最后也是死在了。
黎明前
当年有很多
这种尝试的
齐霞镇翘掌柜说
豆瓣真的是
我的精神启蒙
开始完豆瓣之后
是在互联网
冲浪最快乐的几年。
特别是八祖
从此明星是路人
这个概念
深深刻进了我脑海里。
玩过八祖很难追星。
八祖应该还是
女权主义
最早萌芽的平台之一。
大大启发当时
刚成年的我
豆瓣小组
让各种有兴趣爱好的人。
聚集在一起
有很多干货铁
信息集中都高
用户交互感很强
而这样的社区平台以后。
可能再也不会出现了。
类似他的
像不安他活在海水而我。
说那时候
每次网页改版
都会引起首页一片。
讨论狂潮
所以那个时候
我们做了
豆瓣的截图相册
感觉豆瓣用户
是最爱讨论改版的。
当然现在
爱不更新
也会有人讨论
也是最爱把老板
挂在嘴边了
到现在天天
什么都得叫个阿北。
阿北
有灵时代
天天抢豆瓣
大笨中的第一条回复。
没有App的那会。
我和大学的好朋友。
哪怕出去玩
都会在手机瀏覽器上刷新豆瓣。
和有灵互动
真的是非常美好的回忆。
有灵时代
我在刚才想
他究竟说的是
有灵
除了有灵之间
最早出名的几个组。
文艺青年装逼会
我们爱讲冷笑话
月亮组
警涛抛销组
还有警涛抛销组
感觉跟第八有
去同工就没有
警涛抛销组
扩弧
它有个规矩
在这个组里发帖
必须后面
跟三个以上的感叹号。
可以理解
还有一发帖
就会被封禁的
史上最沉默小组等等。
这都是什么组
这个行为艺术
有点意思
还流行直播楼
追直播
豆瓣没有只看
楼主的功能
还有人专门建立
给直播楼
脱水的小组
还有超级搞笑的
比如说阳城岗
狂热追随者小组
里面不管发生了什么？
都得说
都他们来刚刚
都是什么？
这些人玩挺热闹
俄祖也是神铁无数。
火鸡味锅
电鸡手环
打散米饭
等等
特别好玩
豆瓣好玩的
这是太多了
哪怕现在不会那么重度。
刷豆瓣了
每天会点开
看一看
每天还会点开看
恶用米西
这位朋友说
知乎对我来说是美人。
我和老公
在知乎上认识的
我注意他是
他发过一个关于
相关的帖子
觉得回答角度很刁钻。
就翻到了他刚来我们城市。
发的一个交友帖
鬼使神差的刘乐延。
我们一周后见面
一个月后决定关系。
一年后结婚了
其实见面前
基本就已经
聊到热火朝天了
因为确认过关注
就知道是对的人
你看那个年
社区里面
你通过内容
能找到同号
同类
关注的东西很相像。
工作有交集
年龄都不小
现在算是很通评
高校我们也都会
把坏脾气丢给AI。
不互相传递负能量。
AI梳理完思路
再平和吵架
非常好
冰箱上还有一起定的家规。
留言板上有各自
工作一周规划
以方便接娃
玄关门上有注意事项。
谁说这不是
当年发铁石的思路。
梳理呢？
这也太值得学习了。
很多经营家庭的
亲密关系的人
确实都可以
从你们这个行为的。
细节当中
抽取到很多
有意义的地方
Chris舒哥说。
我是知乎的黄威
优秀回答者
十多年也亲身体验到。
知乎由专业性文字平台。
到社会热点平台的转变。
我万赞的回答
都是和专业性无关的话题。
而是和热点和情绪有关。
知乎也尝试过很多。
变现的方式
知乎咨询
知识商单
置知计划等等
最后发现赚钱的
还是演选小说
目前知乎
还是我日常用的
最多的APP
但我的创作热情
也确实被公众号
小红书波克分散了不少。
希望知乎还是不要不。
天涯的后臣
能坚守中国互联网文字。
平台最后的阵地
飞翔的荷兰豆说
还记得当年
贴巴和新浪NBA。
已经是各种漫漫的时候。
虎铺还是一股清流。
当时算是国内
比较专业的篮球论坛。
到现在这个时间点。
虎铺没有任何的版权。
甚至放一个新闻里面。
连GIF图都放不了。
这个也是
这几年我才了解到的规则。
就是你没有世界杯的转播权。
或者NBA的转播权。
你动途是不能放的。
只能放净途
因为动途多了
它确实就是视频了。
飞翔的荷兰豆说
再加上现在整个论坛的氛围。
除了互相骂就是阴阳怪气。
根本就没有人
能好好讨论一个问题了。
加上各种
带节奏的发帖员
和无处不在的广告。
也难怪后来一直上不了诗。
这是他的一个视角。
当然也可以看出来。
虎铺跟当年
很多人回忆中的虎铺。
也不一样了
有点爱之深
走之切的那个意思。
安金桥
布林德说
豆瓣大概是06年。
大学师有推荐过
就顺手注册了
一度算是小组的中渡用户。
通过小组都有的
线下桌游群
认识了现在的妻子。
现在基本上不用了。
知乎看了眼个人页面。
15年的注册时间了。
反正也是邀请至过去的。
没记错
应该是微博上关注了白鸭。
他放了几个4块钱的邀请码。
就用上了
他拿来4块钱卖了。
加了点门槛
他说去过地灵界
严大会
北京古楼
西边一个酒吧？
后来认识很多
同为球迷的知乎朋友。
时不时会提球
有时候还会邀请上。
知乎的
比如说黄继心
李深深
这些都是创始人
只说球技
继心是不如深深的。
我大概是15年左右。
就不太在知乎火月了。
实在不喜欢泛化后的。
社区氛围
偶尔发发回答
日常当厕所独屋摔一摔。
还有个知乎朋友群。
日常聊聊天
也就这样了
而贴巴是纯路人
虎铺
我是反虎腹狗派
因为我是足球迷
当时
就是我之前说那个狗嗨。
他说那个狗嗨
就是狗嗨
他们都泥称叫他狗孩。
他说就是反虎腹狗派。
他那个时候是狗孩。
搞一个线上冰轮赛。
被球迷朋友叫去玩。
不成想长远ID被占了。
于是走后门
还把ID要了回来。
刚想在狗孩玩玩
就整合成虎铺足球了。
于是也就不打去了。
想想
之前在互联网输出最多的。
一是知乎
二是更早更垂直的足球论坛。
只能说
知乎也没有走成
我想要的样子
也许会走得更久了。
这个言语之间
能不能听出来
在这个早年网上
还是有一定影响力的。
那评论区
我们今天就聊到这了。
好嘞
本大帖第214期。
啥清
我们下期再见
欢迎在小宇宙
苹果
PoseCast。
喜马拉雅
网易音乐
Spotify
豆瓣
订阅和收听
版达铁
也欢迎分享和转发。
我是本期之路人
默在T
祝大家新的一周生活愉快。
我们下期再见咯
拜拜